hello everybody thank you for tuning in
to this episode of the last word this
one is going to be a little bit
different our guest today is one of um
very special nature so that being said
we've only got him for a limited amount
of time so what we want to do first is
spend our time chatting with him
let him get back to his his world and
his family and everything and then we'll
take a little pause
get a cut and then we will come back and
talk about all things beyond light just
between cognito and i so
cognito in proper fashion let's bring
our guest in
no doubt all right we're live y'all
welcome to the last word
episode number 128 and it's a glorious
thursday
thursday that's true and we're back in
front of the campfire for some more
lunar shooting discussion
i'm extremely excited about our special
guests so we're going to get right into
it
i want to introduce a lord who is not
only responsible for some of the most
iconic themes and soundtracks within the
destiny universe
but whose talents sonically evoke a wide
array of emotions
within our video game film and record
industry
introducing the music director slash
composer at bungie
and co-founder of the sound chemistry
record label
the lord of music production and sound
design
all the way from the drums of halo reach
to the frigid sounds of europa and the
deep stone crypt
live from pacific standard time and
making his debut at the campfire of the
last word
my man lord skye lewin how you doing sir
i'm doing well thank you so much good to
have you here man long overdue i know
we've been talking a bit you know to get
you on we appreciate you taking the time
man first off quickly
how are you doing in the midst of this
whole
you know beyond light launch and
everything else just how you surviving
through everything
oh yeah well thanks thanks for having me
good to be here yeah it's been uh it's
been a good time like i'm
you know working on working on this
stuff is always fun so i i can't
complain
nice nice nice man so we're gonna get
hit the ground running because we know
time is limited
so you want to set it off should i set
it off how do you want to do sir
you made it of course i muted it
i was letting you have your time that's
how this works i had to give you your
time
no um first thing i just wanted to if
you just want to kind of tell people
a little bit of your background in how
much of kind of the destiny music you've
been through and
also just you know what music you worked
on previously just kind of
what they would potentially know you
from before we dive into more of the
details
cool yeah so with with bungie and
destiny um
i played some drums like you mentioned
on halo reach and odst that was kind of
my
uh introduction to bungie um and then
i got involved doing composition on d1
wrote a bunch of uh
pieces of music that are in the game and
shortly thereafter was uh invited to
join the team and joined the team in
what was that uh
december of 2014 i think
as a composer and um so worked on you
know
uh house of wolves taking king
as a composer and then um in 2016 moved
into the role that i'm in now as music
director still still also composing but
um you know that was rise of iron was
our first release with me in that role
and um you know basically doing that
thing
still so having a blast and uh before
bungie
i did a bunch of work in you know in
records but uh
mostly tv and film um in various roles
like
um i worked on a series called entourage
that
people know about some people don't
pretty fun series though if you haven't
seen it you definitely should
um and and several others um the most
recent one
being uh fargo and banshee uh banshee
was a really
pretty awesome show as was fargo so
those were both a blast to work on and
uh
you know kind of a bit of everything so
cool actually you transitioned right
into one of my questions which is in
reference to that because you got this
very
this vast like diverse career in my
opinion and like when i seen you know
the things you worked on again like you
said csi miami
entourage one of my favorite shows on
hbo and um you know
even the the karate kid that we make so
um what i was gonna say is how does
that differ for you musically in
comparison to what you do now as far as
like in the game industry
um well there's there's two parts to
that answer let's see so first
the role like in in tv like entourage
there's not a score it's all
songs so my role in that was as a music
editor and that's a very different thing
than composing music
um i did compose a little music that was
in that you know but they were
tracks you know what i mean not like
score um
but for a show like that the score is
made up of songs and so taking a piece
of
of existing music and molding it to fit
a scene and score a scene is
you know a whole different skill set
than actually composing music because
composing music is more about
identifying and conveying an emotion
whereas taking a piece of music
is but you have less control over that
and so it's more about
where you place certain parts of the
music under the scene and
um i could go on much
longer that's why you're here we want to
get started
from the legend today get the inside
baseball of the music world
exactly exactly but yeah i mean
i i suppose when it comes to composition
especially for video games it's
it's a different muscle like composition
in general is
is you know very much about that emotion
and emoting
conveying an emotion and making sure
that that emotion matches and supports
and enhances the media that it
accompanies
and with a video game it's not linear
it's never the same
twice through i mean there are
exceptions like cinematics and you know
cut scenes etc those things they are
like
mini versions of tv or film but
with the gameplay itself the the music
has to
be able to survive in any number of
different
experiences so every time you play it
it's going to play back differently and
and being able to
track that and follow that is necessary
and that's one of my favorite parts
about working in
in games and non-linear media is having
to
think about that and build the music in
a way that
can accomplish that right but still
convey
what you want to convey as a composer
and still convey the right emotions in
the right places and
you know tv and film it's very much like
this thing's always going to be here
you know there's conforms and you're
changing the way the music fits against
picture as the picture evolves and
you know there are things that have to
happen in that
medium to to polish it and you know get
it to the state it needs to be in when
it when it goes out but
that state is a moving target in games
and i love that it makes it
a whole a whole other type of challenge
very very that more dynamic i would
assume
exactly absolutely what you got man
uh yeah i mean that just kind of takes
into the next piece and
that's why uh when you talk about games
you have to think of especially destiny
being an open
world game you drive around you go into
a lost sector you could boot
off a mission it's not like when you
picture an old game you're like oh you
play through a level and it may loop a
track or do some variations you close
a mission you go to the next one very
distinct certain stops you could roam
around
on any planet in destiny for a while and
get different themes that play
different tones that come in how do you
guys actually
like what is the process to decide you
know what track kind of plays where
how is it i mean it does it can't just
be it's not like an audio slider one
goes off and then the other just like
i've heard things of like tracks almost
like well truly like they dynamically
build like you start here and if you get
to a certain progression and you add
more notes or
instruments or things like that i was
just kind of curious if you go into
details
how you handle an open world or how kind
of the tracks progress as
you know you play a game like destiny
versus say like mario brothers when it's
like
start to finish very very different
right well i mean there's
there is an aspect of that you know like
the the activity the campaign activities
have
more of that mario brothers sort of feel
where it is a start to finish thing but
there
there can be hybrids where it's a little
bit of free roam in moments or
you hit a certain spot and you could go
off and get sidetracked doing something
else and then come back to your
your goal and um being able to support
all that is kind of part of that
dynamic nature of games that i was
talking about but yeah i guess
without getting too into the details
that i shouldn't talk about
that we don't want to get you into
channels only
[Laughter]
each destination will score with what we
will call a palette internally we'll
we'll say okay this this destination
needs to convey these things
we want to make sure these emotions and
this feel is in the score
or or comes across to the player and so
the score is is built with that in mind
for a destination
but then there are activities that
happen in the destination that may
deviate from that and so we have to plan
for those things and score those things
and then getting from one to the other
in a musical way that transitions and
doesn't sound bad
is part of it um
and i guess the best way to put it is
like yeah they're kind of like two
different
at least two different approaches to how
we would play music and one of them is
you're out in the world you're doing
you know something in free roam and the
other is it's a you know
campaign and it's a very linear um
in a non-linear way activity um
and so within those two we have several
ways of
approaching it and probably won't get
into that in too much detail but
hopefully that answers your question at
least no that's fine actually um
you actually answered about two parts of
the different questions
which is cool which one was um you know
hearing you michael and the team always
reference like
the destiny gravy so to speak you know
saying like what
what could concocts it and how that and
i think you did a good job of kind of
explaining
you know what i'm saying again you have
like you said the mario brothers stuff
which is the campaign which is set
whatever but then there's things that
it's an open world
and stuff like that but the thing that
really impressed me was i think
something you said at um
gdc or gdc way back um game developers
conference
and how like destiny's game engine is
able to play
music that changes dynamically you know
what i'm saying
so i guess the other part of this that i
wanted to ask you was that
as far as the input right how much input
do you guys have over that
in control to in comparison to maybe say
like a bunch as far as where the way
things go in that direction is it is it
like 50 50 as much as you could talk
about obviously we don't want to get you
in trouble
yeah yeah well first uh just yeah
team you mentioned team just make sure
like our team is awesome that's
the best part about it so i just gotta
call that out salute the best team
the best team i got a new truck yeah no
the peop the people that we
that we get to work with are are all
phenomenal and none of this would be
any good without the people so i'm glad
you mentioned that i just had to
pause there but yeah to answer your
question the um
yes we have a good amount of control
over that and yeah the gdc talk you're
referring to kind of went into some
details on that and and i can kind of
recap them
the uh the gist of it is and and this
this is something we constantly evolve
and change over time but
the gist of it is when you're in free
roam you get what we call the ambient
playlist the ambient state and that just
plays music that feels like the place
and it has different things from the
place so in in this case europa
there's elements that that in each queue
represent different things
about europa and that as a whole
that ambient um music kind of tells a
story about europa
and it can play whenever but then as you
do things within
free roam the music can change and does
follow
the experience and that happens through
a couple of different ways but the one
we talked about at the gdc talk was
was what we call our music system and
that
basically allows us to use script calls
to
change intensities in the music and then
how we design
the music to respond to those script
calls can vary
but the the basic output is that
when you hear a certain change in the
music it's following a script call
that might say oh do this here and then
we get to this moment in this activity
do that or maybe it's stop or maybe it's
go back to ambient or you know
it could be any number of those
different things but the idea is that
it's it's sort of a bridge between being
purely in the ambient state musically of
free roam
and a fully curated um
campaign like a haymaker or something
it's it's it's in the middle of those
and and we can
transition from one to the other through
this system and it gives us the ability
to
to kind of support the the gameplay in a
way that still feels like destiny
oh i gave i'm sorry getty no no i was
gonna say it always feels like destiny
and that's one thing for six years
and shout out to cognito i'm going to
steal his thunder a little bit he has
been championing for you guys to win
awards for sound for just literally
years you'll see the nominations got
once again game awards come up and be
like dude where is destiny
on the music you guys are getting
snubbed it's not cool i'm on the front
lines i'm on the front last guy
i'm i'm like the champion for the team
man i'm like
it is a travesty that elites my thing
of course you got some bias for disney
fit but you guys are amazing
and i i just feel it's a travesty that
there's no nominations
the only thing i can think about is
maybe they're categorizing uh
you destiny two as the original release
and they're not counting each expansion
as a separate thing and that's what i
feel is just this is criminal man
it's criminal what's happening to you
guys i just wanted to put that out there
okay i just i
gotta fight the good fight for you guys
all the time but we appreciate it
yeah i mean that's yeah you may be right
yeah i was like we've always wondered
how the yeah the nominations go but
that's one of those four
you guys take something as as big as
shadow keep or
beyond light and again you can talk as
little as you have to about that one i
understand uh
but even say something like shadow keep
you
you try and i want to know like when you
guys get to
well i'll two questions but i'll do them
kind of in separate places but take
something like shadow keep or beyond
light
and we have like the theme of shadow
keep is something
a lot of people would think fear like
fear is in the theme the underlying
tones that you guys have and the music
and it can take like
three notes and some of the notes you
guys hit just make like the hair stand
up on the back of your neck which is
really good for you guys doing your job
insanely well but it was like
if somebody's just like hey this is all
about nightmares if somebody gives you
just that as like
do they when you go to start composing
do you get something like
hey we're working on this next expansion
it's got something like nightmares
in it do you what does that start doing
in your head and where do you start
going with something
even as vague as that or is that how the
process even gets to begin for you
or do you come in the process like you
know the whole story about eris the
pyramid and all this other stuff how
when do you start getting involved and
then what happens
as soon as you do okay so
yeah first i'll just say yeah maybe the
expansion thing has to play
some part in that i i don't know but i
appreciate you
you're rooting for us i got it yeah as
far as getting involved with
with the process i mean that's the best
part about being
in in a studio and working the way we do
is we're involved like from the
beginning and it's very collaborative
um we generally know what the story is
shaping up to be when we start
but it may not be finished and so we're
often
kind of tracking the changes as they
evolve
and we might start with you know like
rise of iron is a perfect example we had
one piece of concept art and five key
words
and so the the theme the theme that came
out of that was
was really targeted at something that we
thought we understood based on those
six pieces of information but as we
started to
you know really ingest what the story
was we were able to flush it out and
push it more in that direction and so
that's kind of our process is
start with whatever we have when we need
to start and evolve
with everything else which is definitely
different than you know say tv or film
which is much more like
hey here's in most cases there are
certainly exceptions but in most cases
it's like here's the edit lock and we're
going to spot this and
then we're going to score it and it'll
change a little bit but the story is
mostly the same and like the scenes have
already been shot but in games it could
be like
we think it's going to do this
maybe that's that's also fun oh wow
wow but uh but yeah i mean there there's
very much
um there's very much evolution through
the process
iteration and kind of following what
what things are
turning into and making sure that what
we're doing supports that
enough speaking of which um i have to
ask this too
in reference to that process right which
is the team
and i would say like debating on on
choices and direction sonically and
stuff like that and i've heard you know
discussions obviously with yourself
and my even reference to you there's a
kind of like
these creative debates where maybe in
the past you have fought for a specific
theme on how
this a specific segment and destiny
should sound and like
how intense does it get or maybe could
you give an example of a moment like
this in the past where it's just like
you're like no i feel this whether it be
character or theme or setting should
represent this and maybe you're getting
some pushback like
how often i heard him maybe i was gonna
say i heard somebody got punched in a
previous interview but
all right i don't think there's anything
quite like that
is that serious guy no no physical no
beat em ups no brawlers
i mean if if that happens i'm
fortunately not a part of it
salute to you um yeah i know but but
yeah we have conversations and
sometimes people don't agree on what
something should be but um
i mean that's one of the cool things
about bungie is that
it is my job to help define what that is
in the music and that's unusual
in in a lot of um in a lot of cases and
so
having a voice in that process and not
just being like
a person whose job is to provide a score
that hits somebody else's box of check
marks
is is one of the best things about
bungie for
us and our team um but but really what
we're doing is
we're bringing our voice to the table
and you know we have those discussions
sometimes somebody
feels very strongly that this thing
should happen right
sometimes they're right and sometimes
we're right and it really doesn't matter
who's
right what matters is how do we make
this the best that we can make it
right and being open to everybody's
opinions and everybody's input
that's that's what matters in my opinion
and you know i think our team does a
really good job of
of keeping that balance so that we keep
the priority in mind and not like
worrying about
well my idea didn't make it in like you
know
[Laughter]
take it up i mean it's got to be a fine
line i would say sometimes only because
of again the passion you guys put in and
i i guess where the questions kind of
stemmed from because i'm just kind of
thinking
again you mentioned something like razer
vine you mentioned like having maybe six
of pieces of things to work with
or things like that but i was also
thinking okay well maybe the narrative
team comes in
and they have an idea or someone else
has an idea and
you really emotionally may feel
something i just want to say like
like you know eventually i know you guys
come to that
middle ground kind of thing but i i
guess by course like how often does that
thing kind of happen i meant to say well
i mean you mean like collaboration
or or like conflict during collaboration
more of a conflict sonically
of maybe the way something should sound
pretty rare i mean for the most part
like it almost never happens i think the
i could maybe think of a couple of
examples where we had discussions where
there wasn't necessarily alignment early
on
um you know trying to think like
really maybe only one but and it really
in the end it like kind of worked out it
worked itself out
which one's got come on i want to say it
but i can't get into much details
okay so on d2 and in in
in the activity where journey plays
let's say you know
a very orchestral approach to scoring
that activity um yes
and i won't say what we also were
considering doing but there was a strong
desire to do something else
and i felt strongly that it should be
what it turned into
and we had those discussions and you
know
kind of got to the point where we all
landed where it landed but
you know what i mean that was maybe
maybe the only example of something like
that that i could think of but it
again it wasn't conflict it was just
discussion and like
getting getting all of the reasons and
the you know
the why's out there complaining it was
really more just like
development like the process that that
we should be going through and
a lot of times alignment just happens
right out of the gate and there isn't
that
but when there is more discussion
involved like that that might be an
example of it
no that's actually actually a great
example thank you for that that's
actually i was very curious about that
but you got e
uh i just kind of i was like i feel like
i'm gonna probably tackle the elephant
in the room here but i honestly wanted
to see
how i guess what has been kind of the
most challenging
over the past year because it has been
one hell of a year
um but also i would say like what have
you guys gained
by going through this past year as a
team like
obviously there were challenges faced
and remotely in things but i would say
where
where you guys see yourself like now
having released something like beyond
light where do you think you've
you know seen positivity out of it too
um yeah so yeah working remotely has
been interesting
um certainly things that are more
difficult
especially when there's large amounts of
data involved but
um you know i think once we got over
those hurdles which we did get over
pretty quickly
it actually in some ways almost kind of
feels like normal i mean
we miss the human interaction of like
especially composing where we're all in
the room together and we're
you know like the vibe that kind of
happens when
when you can be in the studio with other
people it still happens
over like a virtual meeting but it's not
quite the same you know
but yeah i mean i think if anything
that's probably the thing i miss the
most is the like
the the in-person interaction and the
just the magic that can happen
i mean is it almost kind of like without
any plan like a garage band
jam session sometimes if you guys are
working on something to get into a
rhythm is it
is it almost like that for you guys yeah
i know you could call it that i mean
like sometimes it's like hey
i have this idea come listen to it and
then that turns into like ooh ooh ooh
and then like
you know three hours later without
really meaning to
we walk out and we're like oh this is
going to be cool sorry i missed that
meeting you know
every once in a while something like
that happens and letting that magic
happen is
is really key and it's harder to do when
you're remote but it still happens
because
you know just just virtually tell
someone
i gotta skip this meeting or i'm gonna
be late or whatever um
yeah zoom call somebody at three in the
morning dude i had a note pop into my
head we have to talk
oh no no the three in the morning thing
is real oh
wow i was joking okay who woke who up
not usually like calling each other but
like you know people might wake up at
three in the morning with an idea
and sketch it out just so that we don't
forget it because you know what you go
back to sleep and you wake up and you're
like oh what was it
ah i should have i should have recorded
it or i should have like written it down
and so
we're we're pretty good at that i mean
mike mike uh just did that
recently wow and it was actually three
in the morning which is why i thought it
was funny
that's like the time most people are
sleeping but for you guys working all
hours it could you could be awake you
never know
so or you're sleeping and you just you
have an idea and you you got to wake up
to write it down
that's kind of awesome so is there like
a notepad next to all of the um you know
composers beds at all time to be like i
gotta write it down
that i don't know but i have one yeah
that is nice not a good question i mean
i just i i really
definitely wanted to to harp on that
because you know one of the things you
know
obviously interviewing a lot of
developers interviewing different people
in the games industry
you know we forget you know being in a
pandemic
and the thing that i was told obviously
was um
motion capture um and then the second
thing is obviously orchestra and music
how impacted that is so it has a
fantastic question because
you forget like this this is almost like
we got consoles launching in a pandemic
and then we have an
orchestra launching it these are
different times so salute to the team
yeah for you guys
to still be able to do your jobs to kind
of adapt on the fly
and and still put out this amazing
product so
salute on that and then the second thing
is i know we can't touch too much but
i gotta commend you you know obviously
picking up the beyond light soundtrack
and just hearing like this whole feel
you know the cold storms the europa the
feel you know
and then obviously the ominous level of
the pyramid so it's like
again is it a similar situation where
you know
kind of pieces are just given to you and
then you guys are allowed to expound
upon kind of thing or was it more
detailed than even rise of iron as far
as what you're allowed to
kind of formulate in your minds um
no i mean it's it's pretty much always
like we get the information about what
what the destination's
going to be what we're trying to to tell
the story of there
what the destination looks like and even
if that's not
finished when we start we kind of like i
said track it as it grows and as it
becomes what it's going to be and so
our job is to represent that in the
music
and you know however that comes about
can be different on each release
sometimes we have more information
earlier sometimes we have less
information earlier or sometimes
you know every release has a different
set of circumstances i guess but
it's always our job to define what it's
going to sound like musically
and and that's um that part doesn't
change i guess
nice yeah tremendous standouts for me i
want to give you guys a couple shout
outs um
beyond like the actual intro track fire
fight
love it i believe that that's you you're
first credited i believe right
with that one right as far as i mean
like everything's a team effort like the
the way credits go like we will often
credit somebody first if it's like oh
the melody that's in there
they started it but even if somebody
starts something usually everybody's got
their hands in it
i agree
yeah for sure i love it i'm actually
learning but the fact that he said that
i'm actually
learning a lot and as far as that
process but i want to give you that
shout out for that
on the team um fallen empire was another
standout for me
um every time he would he go into any of
the bray tech
uh research facilities um frigid tomb
very good well very very stands out i
always like what bungie
like you guys do like uh dark computer
tech themes and
evil machines going like the music
always fits but there's one i gotta talk
about this is what i got to talk about
probably the way i can't talk about what
i'm gonna talk about that
sky kit elaborate on oh i'm sure yeah
which is unveiled i don't know
what's happening and unveiled but that
sounds like the most ominous
darkest guys if you guys got the
soundtrack
unveiled i don't know what's going on i
i'm scared of what we're gonna face
when that track whatever that track is i
haven't heard it in the game yet
so whatever that hits oh boy i wouldn't
shout you guys out for that well cool i
appreciate it yeah i i won't
spoil it yes yes correct good good good
good good good
but salute man again just a very ominous
foreboding you know this whole almost
feels like a boss fight but
i really want to shout you guys out
because this soundtrack is
really really solid i'm really enjoying
it and i got a chance to really deep
down for this so salute to the team i
mean i love what you guys did with this
one
right on thank you so much y'all make
sure and let him know absolutely
absolutely which gaddy
yeah um no i'm just sitting there like
trying to think of all the songs and
stuff
no but when you guys like go through and
you know obviously
the theme of beyond light is freezing
your ass off is the nice way to say it
i mean it's like the whole place is cold
but when i just that's again i wanted to
compliment you guys as well it's like
how do you and you go through and you
just i've been like
playing a lot and then i like had the
soundtrack i've been playing in the last
few days as you were coming and just
like
when you somebody describes how do you
make music sound cold
and i want to say you got i that sounds
ridiculous but i want to say you guys
nailed it like yes like the tracks the
sounds like there's three the
bum bum bum bump but like the the few
themes that you guys have in there and
it's like
there's seven notes and this is kind of
where i'm leading with my question
there are certain aspects when you guys
get to musics that if you listen to a
whole soundtrack there's like
very specific thematic like you know
little tiny chunks that happen in there
i don't know
like proper term hook or anything of
that nature of what you'd call it but
when it comes to like those little
sections
that seem to be a thematic piece in a
lot of places
like how do those how much deliberation
happens on those is that one of those
that's a 3am the seven notes happened to
you
i was like is that like something that
has that much like it feels like it's
got a lot of weight through an entire
soundtrack
um is that one of those that some just
the epiphany happens on one you guys is
like
you know eureka like the whole
soundtrack has a theme now or how does
how does something that specific come up
and if you have any idea what i'm
talking about i don't know but it's
there's a certain theme that happens a
lot that i noticed
yeah yeah no there's there's a few um
each release has at least
one usually more and like yeah they're
themes or motifs they represent certain
things in the story or certain
certain elements of the game that that
are central to the story and that
um that is always very intentional
process but
yeah it could be a 3 a.m or it could be
like they can come up in
any way in any combination of ways like
there are no rules there it's just like
once once we we have something that's a
contender for a certain place it's
usually pretty
it's pretty obvious to me what needs to
go in each place or if we have something
that's close
and maybe we can push it to fit a
certain place and that hasn't been
filled yet when we're
trying to you know put those together
it's my job to kind of direct the
this piece is so close to doing blah if
we just do x y and z
now it's going to fit there perfectly
and that place is covered that theme is
covered you know that motif is covered
and so
yeah there's there's a handful of those
in in this in every destiny release but
there's also like the ones that keep
coming back that are just
you know the gravy as you mentioned
before that yes that
uh yeah those are those are part of the
guardian
dude i love it man i love it um because
you know going back to to
past expansions and we're talking about
those themes and again i got to salute
the team because
i know um me being the warlock and
osiris fan why i have to mention this
um curse of osiris you know i know this
soundtrack from a gameplay i mean
the soundtrack the game the expansion
itself from a gameplay standpoint a lot
of people weren't happy with
but from a musical standpoint this thing
was amazing and um
one thing i i got from it very egyptian
very there's a track particular that
really resonates it's called tree of
probabilities
and this thing is like angelic to me it
is just
it is amazing what is going on right you
know i feel like i'm in the middle of
egypt and there's pyramids around me
it's something happening
when that track comes on so again what i
did
what i did notice what you said like
that that that theme
kind of res some some parts of it that
theme resonates in other songs and other
tracks of that soundtrack
and i just i thought that one was
another one like how did you guys get to
that place as far as um particularly
that expansion
you know was that what did you guys say
hey you know we feel this should be a
more of an egyptian thing
or again collaboration with narrative
team or anything like that i was very
curious because i
absolutely loved that one yeah yeah i
mean like always the
the uh the process comes from
us getting the information so like once
we know okay this has
these elements to it we'll put our
our spin on it and then have those
conversations and and
you know that um like like most of them
was a thing that we
we kind of just felt was the right
approach and yeah it worked in that case
and that's what we went with but
um like like you mentioned the themes
that kind of recur in many of the queues
like
just more broadly and musically speaking
yes um
that theme in that release and or that
theme of one of the themes in that
release will come back in different ways
and different palettes and the
the palettes are like the production
choices of this
combination of instruments and this
arrangement or this combination of
techniques that accomplish this sound
and so sometimes like to that point
we'll have a melody that
that does what you're explaining but
then we'll also present it
in a completely different palette and
you know production
and arrangement where it doesn't sound
like that at all and yep
those like breadcrumbs if you will kind
of connect the dots and make
make the whole experience cohesive from
a musical standpoint
[Music]
you nailed it yeah i gotta steal one
more question because
he's on to something where i was going
to go which is again what he just said
that that thread that connective
tissue that kind of theme and again
where it happened which is again one of
my
favorite tracks of forsaken you guys
don't get enough credit
i feel it's the greatest redeemed ever
when i heard this track
it was um forsaken i believe it's called
the tracks called shell of what was
when that dick
did when that hits it's on
like that so and and not only was
i was like blown away from it then i
heard like isn't it
yeah whatever i think on the soundtrack
it's called that it was like
where it is yeah yeah it's called quiz
walk so shelby was crazy well
but then there's also a piece of that
and shout out to fortes
if he's in the chat when you play gambit
and and you know get drifters talking
and it's that same
theme you know what i'm saying i
absolutely that's one of my favorite i
who shout out to everybody involved with
that one
greatest rape music period i'm gonna
answer my seat
salute right on well yeah like i said
thanks to the team i mean we we have
a great group of people that we work
with and none of what we do would be
what it is without them so hello
man so like one of mine is kind of
asking
like what is your kind of asking like a
process piece to understand like
when you go to write a piece of music
and you may not have done whisper but i
have to mention whisper because that is
such
a unique whole ball of wax in there
because the tone the ominousness the
color like
that whole thing was put together and
that's like a one-off two for you guys
when you get to do that
you're like here's one mission not like
a whole expansion
here's one mission very unique from a
lot of things
when you go to start like you know
writing
that piece of music the themes the like
behind the
scenes tunes and stuff that are going on
in there where do you
start is there like instruments you
start messing with first is there
do you want to work on like the little
like a little melody part build around
that
like where where do you begin and what's
your process to like just build a piece
of music
i know that's the cliche of what's your
process but yeah it's like i know
okay the answer is yes they have it
happens in every possible way you could
think of um
sometimes you do start with a melody
sometimes you start with
a sonic choice or a palette or a
production aesthetic or
you know like a vibe like i want this
emotion and i could get it 20 different
ways which way feels right
it's kind of an exploration but a lot of
times it just kind of happens naturally
like you're
you're looking at the thing that you're
building and
it makes decisions for you and as a
composer your job is to kind of listen
to those
and follow but also kind of like like
walking a dog like you got your leash
and you're
you're saying yep you can go that way oh
no no don't go over there you know what
i mean
you're kind of guiding the process but
like it's happening through you in a way
not like you're not necessarily
it's almost like you're listening more
than
like trying to write something out
you're like where does it want to go
next
and letting it tell you but then if it
wants to go next somewhere that doesn't
fit and your job is to keep it
constrained into where it does fit like
don't go off the path
puppy like in that analogy you got to
kind of constrain it and hold it back
you know or or direct it in a different
way that works and
um i guess that's kind of like a little
bit of a side tangent to your question
but like
in general like with whisper we started
with a very specific
visual and like a very specific vibe
that we were trying to hit and the
the direction we went with the score was
very much influenced with that
like that visual and the goal and what
it was going to feel like right off the
bat and
it was like one of the first times we'd
done something that was that different
and it was
really a blast because of that so that
one
that one specifically is one of mine
because i spent way too much time in
that machine anyway so i learned the
music very very well
but um just the fact that it was so
different from so many things the ahmed
like
was all talking to you occasionally in
the background just like the like
longer like bass notes that would kind
of come through just kind of linger for
a little bit
just so much in that one was just like a
stark contrast from like hey it's all
bright on and it's just
instantly dark in this like sideways
angular cave you're trying to understand
you're trying not to die and then like
in the background like the
and that's why i like what you guys the
way you said that is
any song that you guys put into the game
wherever it goes in whisper
a raid battle a strike a lost sector
wandering around the world
it tells a story and that's like the
story and the journey that we get to go
on when we hear some of the music that
you two guys put together
the game would be empty without it it
has amazing gun play like tell everybody
at bungie we love all their work there's
no question
but it's like each piece of it builds
together and that's why i was like when
you harp on the teams but like
when you hear the soundtrack building
the world and it's it's
i guess the weird compliment is
sometimes when you don't notice things
as much as when they're almost doing the
things the best
like the music is doing what it's doing
so well
that i'm not like oh this note i heard
it's like no like i feel like i'm in a
weird area and the feeling comes from
everything coming together
and that was just kind of a compliment i
wanted to pay to all of you guys
um i did want to ask you quickly though
like when it comes to because i've seen
you do even some like
teaching tutorials about music software
and stuff like that um
but we also talked about notepad do you
have a preference like i mean you
picture some i was talking to somebody
like what would you ask a composer
they're like well do they prefer
handwritten or software it's like
are there ups and downs to software
versus like old handwritten things or do
you have a preference
one way or the other i'm sure it's both
but i guess there's probably ups and
downs but i was curious your thoughts
yeah no for sure it is both and i guess
it's also context like
my my favorite way to compose is with an
instrument like whether it's like pick
up the guitar pick up
you know a vibraphone or a keyboard or
whatever and actually play it
like that that's kind of how i got into
music was playing music
so for me that's the most natural way
but playing
music as a composer is more like hearing
it in your inner ear
and then making it happen making it come
into existence from there and
there are so many ways to do that i
think you know
the paper version i love that that's
kind of where i started you know as a
a student of music was like writing it
down
and like then bringing that to a group
of people to play it
because as a performer and a musician
like that was kind of my my
introduction and then later i got into
production and
actually using you know computers and
software and all the
all the fancy tools we get to use
nowadays and now i love that just as
much and so for me it's more like
what do i have available like if i'm on
an airplane
i'm going to write it on a notepad or
you know on paper with a pen or a pencil
or maybe i'll hum it into my phone and
like go back and produce it later like
it just
the tool is almost irrelevant it's more
just
getting the idea across and so there i
like to explain it to people
as it's like playing an instrument like
you want to have a facility with
whichever of them
you're using to the point where you're
no longer focused on
how you use the tool whether it's a pen
and paper or a you know computer it's
more like
your goal is to get the idea out and
using the tool is completely secondary
and not at all in the way
and like like that's that's the ideal
version of it and so
yeah well all those different kinds of
tools are fun like the phone's probably
the easiest just helmet in your phone
and then you come back and deal with it
humming on an airplane might get to some
people but no
[Laughter]
like that i was like use i was like and
i don't mean this in a bad way it's like
you sound very much of a
creative mind and like that's one of
those things when it
there are bones in your body that like
do not exist in mind for the way you
come about like the way ideas come to
you and the creativity and stuff like
that i'm always so jealous so that's why
i'm always very curious about the
process so
it's very cool to get a little bit of
inside your head
right on well my take on that stuff is
anybody can do it
you just it's like you practice you
might be okay at basketball but you get
really good by playing you know
you're not going to get good by watching
it necessarily and so
it's like a muscle you got to flex and
you got to exercise so to speak
so absolutely absolutely well said well
said
no i know we've been bloviating about
kind of like stuff we like
and stuff like that but what about you
like any
you know obviously it doesn't have to be
beyond life you can't talk about it but
anything as far as destiny universe
specifically you know
are there any tracks that when they play
it
really resonates with you you remember
that like their specialty do you have
any
any babies that you hold dear like these
are
these are my things right i can't i
can't say those i know you're supposed
to pick your favorite kids
but do you have any favorite children
well see the problem with that is not
the favorite children it's the ones that
you don't
want to focus on it's like i guess the
answer to that question is more like
which ones don't i want to hear again
that's a good point no i don't know but
like yeah there's some that i love and
every time i hear them i'm still like
yeah okay that came out cool
i'm still i'm still okay with that one
and there's some that's like oh man i
wish i had like another week to change
this and that and that about the other
one
um but but you know like that's with
everything like
there's a great saying and i forget i
wish i knew who said it i don't know who
said it but
as a musician as an artist as as any
kind of creative
you don't ever finish you just force
yourself to stop
yeah okay it's hands off time that's 100
true even if i don't want to be done
yeah
absolutely but no there are definitely
some some favorites i mean
across the board like i you know i i
love many of them i love the house of
wolves
theme i love rise of iron i love about
no one i love
like journey parts of journey like
jody's fine um
there's too many to mention right but
there's also a few that i would be like
yeah don't listen to that one again
or if i had my way i wouldn't put it on
on my radio like
it doesn't like it's not like i don't
like it you know it's just like
i wish i could have changed that that
little thing right there
yeah i guess that kind of thing it's
like you're like one set out there i'm
stuck with it and now you're like
everybody
like oh i love this thing you're like
i've heard it so many times now
there is that and i guess that's the
like like
the thing that kind of is a good metric
is like if you've heard it so many times
and you still don't mind it after a
while
all right maybe it's not that bad but
like if you start to get bothered by it
i mean it could have used a little more
time
in that save aid are there moments like
that where you know you go to yourself
yeah like you said i wish i had more
time you know
i just need to tweak this but it was
just so well received and you're just
like well okay
like those moments happened i'm trying
to think of any i mean
generally i kind of feel like our our
intuition is pretty
right on like that if we don't like it
it's probably not going to be received
all that well and
part of my job is to not just make the
music but to put the right music in the
right places
and so i generally if i have one that
i'm not super super keen on i'll put it
in a place where it's not super super
like central or focusing um or
you go you go sit over there in the
corner
yeah yeah you could take the bench on
this one that'll be the tess everest
theme when you go
but no i mean for the most part like we
don't want to have those and when i say
that i'm totally joking because
they are things like yeah i like that
cue but that one riff
like i wanted to change this note or man
i wish i could have recorded
that one more take to like fix this part
of it or you know what it's just things
that you know that you wish you could
have done better
that maybe nobody else is ever bothered
by and so
there's really no like actual i hate
that cue it's just like got you no i
just wish i could have
polished it a little bit more before we
sent it out into the world that kind of
thing
oh enough i was like and i kind of
wanted to ask like in that vein
is when it comes to like you could
polish something forever because
everybody always like it's like well
there's this that the other and you kind
of have to make yourself stop
but it is interesting i kind of wonder
just like looking through the entire
soundtrack you have tracks that are like
maybe almost under a minute and a half
and you have some others that are like
five minutes long
when it comes to like even just the
length of some of the tracks that you
guys make is it based on
where it goes in the game for how long
it needs to be or is it just like
you build a piece it is that length and
then they kind of use it where they need
to i kind of
is it just like this song to be two
minutes long
period and this is it sounds good here
or there needs for like longer and
shorter songs
yeah it totally depends on several
things one is
um and there are pieces that are much
longer than five minutes
we what's on the soundtrack is usually
in some cases it's like
exactly what's in the game but in many
cases it's not in most cases it's not
it's usually curated for the soundtrack
which may mean shortened
or abridged or edited um but
like to answer that question i think it
depends on where it's going in the game
and it's kind of our our job to not only
just determine where the music is going
to go
to to help tell the story that we're
telling but also
to keep in mind what it's gonna do in
the gameplay because we are also the
ones who
put the music in the game like we we
script it and implement it and do
do all i mean designers will often write
the script but sometimes we'll actually
write the script
but usually they'll write the script
following our spotting session where we
talk about hey this is where the music
needs to do these things
and then we go and put it in and so
having that information informs how
we write the music or how we cover
that activity or those activities with
the music and so
yeah sometimes it's like oh we know this
context it's going to be blah
you know 90 seconds should be good or
man we need we need
six minutes here i think little ones are
having fun out you're good yeah
i know we all kissed them all yeah it's
almost bedtime for them
that's fair enough fair enough this is
this is real cool just understanding
like i said that process and stuff like
that
and just like i said just looking at
your journey and um you know seeing
where you came from as far as in the
games industry specifically it's pretty
impressive so you actually went back to
drums on this project correct or an army
yeah
okay yeah you talk about that there's
generally a little bit of drums on
on every release but sometimes it's like
um sometimes it's like i'll play a part
because the queue needs it you know i've
done a little bit of guitar and bass
over time and now with josh on our team
he's a much better guitar player than i
am
so i'm pleased to let him do the guitar
playing
um as you you know like all the guitars
on um
on shadowkeep are all josh and um
but yeah it's like whether the score
needs it and
whether we play it or not a lot of times
we'll do a lot of that in
internally and like just record it on
site or now at home
but um you know certain things like
we're not equipped to record an
orchestra
we're gonna go and do that at the studio
and right outside of our
our usual studio i should say but mm-hmm
no fair enough
enough and and to follow up with that um
just in reference to
you know gaming yourself you know what
i'm saying obviously your schedule is
you know immense you got so much on your
play going on and i can only imagine the
demands of bungie at times
but um you know the question for you
like you know do you get a chance to one
play destiny or just in general like
your gaming i know you got a lot of halo
and stuff in
your background and stuff like that do
you get a chance to really game
less now than i used to um partly work
but also family you know like being a
dad definitely
takes more time um in the best possible
way but it does eat into my
uh my chance to play games like i mean
there were there were
years where i played probably way too
much and now i'm on the other end of
that extreme so
it's good it's good to be both yeah yeah
but i do get to play still and
and i would like to play more than i get
you know the more than i have time to
but it's um
it's enough to to kind of feed the needs
so to speak
yeah you got one yeah um
and again you just got to let us know in
time so we always want to be respectful
there so
let us know is
you have like you have destiny one
you've got some kind of established
themes there you've got now
especially as we're literally going
beyond light
playing with the traveler and light
pyramids and darkness it's multiple
subclasses this whole like thing is
going on
i know there can be a lot of challenges
for composing especially is like because
like i kind of want to ask you two
things one what for you is like the most
challenging
aspect of composing music for destiny
itself
and then two now that we're in this
space kind of going forward
is there is it hard to balance like
light and dark
um good first like is that is that
planned to you at all where you kind of
have to almost have like
a heroic ominous theme at the same time
is that like an issue so
kind of two things sorry i'm yeah i know
all good i'm gonna answer your second
question first because it's fresher
um and no i mean that's actually one of
my favorite parts is
getting to do that it's like it's a joy
and a privilege so
um you know like musicians and composers
and probably all creative people
like a little bit of variability i i
certainly do and it's nice to have
that you know change of focus or change
of palette and destiny is amazing for
music in that regard because there's so
much variability in what we get to do
not only from release to release but
just you know within the the palettes
that we create in the world in the game
and that
that's a really fertile playground for a
composer so
um that light and dark like you know you
were talking about
no that's it's more than anything it's
just a ton of fun
to get to be thinking about that and you
know how it's
evolving and tracking all that um
writing for it all of it
um and i think your first question was
challenges yeah just kind of what what
about what's like one of the more
challenging things about composing music
for a game like what's one of the harder
parts just within the whole
job sorry i think that answer
no it's all good um that answer totally
is going to be different for every
person because everyone's
situation is different right but i guess
for for me i think the the most
challenging part is that it's like the
composing while it's one of my favorite
things to do isn't my primary job and so
i have
many other responsibilities that eat up
a lot of my time and so
composing isn't the thing i just do i
don't get to sit down every day all day
and just write music anymore
um so if there's a challenge it's it's
not so much a challenge but it's more
that
that um that balance means that when i
get to compose
i'm like 100 in the zone because i know
okay this is my window i better go
so it's kind of like perform on demand
go
um and and you know like
fortunately that works for me like not
not everybody would but um
it's a thing that i kind of enjoy like
that's cool man especially since the
alternative is like oh maybe maybe i'm
not gonna
um not gonna get to write because i have
30 minutes right now and none until
tomorrow i'd rather write for that 30
minutes so
while it's not not really a challenge i
guess it's a uh
it's a thing that i have to be careful
with to make sure that i'm you know
maintaining the balance basically
absolutely got to be cognizant of that
absolutely yeah absolutely now i know
i've been on my um
you know i'm full fit as far as the the
whole award thing and i'm gonna continue
to pressure the game awards every year
by shouting you guys out of why the
destiny game is not nominated
but one thing i did
was that um you know you guys what an
ass cap
2017 man um was it video game score of
the year
destiny rise of iron so you paul
and michael with that share that award
like how was that experience to be
celebrated in that regard how was that
that was pretty cool um and yeah i mean
ascap's a cool one too because that's
like the composer's choice award
and ascap for people who don't know is
is a society of like
music makers and so you know being
nominated and
and even winning an award from a group
of your peers is a pretty cool
pretty cool thing that's what i'm going
to sleep with at night to feel better
about the snub on vinegar
because i'm like he he was i'm the one
complaining and you're like look my
peers recognize our greatness okay so
you're good you sleep at that i still
toss and turn i'm gonna speak to jeff
keithley we're gonna get it right
now i think it comes down to a
stipulation with expansion but
look man we got we got to change the
process we're going to start the process
right
that expansion should be included as
nominees every year
started by lord cognito here you heard
it here first sky your first vote
beyond light's amazing man that's right
thank you yeah no
no complaints from me there i mean the
the cool thing is there is just so much
good music
i mean video game music is is turned
into a whole other thing from what it
used to be and so
i mean not that you know like the mario
brothers theme is iconic and nobody will
ever forget that
but you know what i mean like music and
video games is is definitely evolved and
so there's there's always amazing music
and and so
i have i have no qualms with with what's
going on there because the music that
gets nominated and wins
it it's always great so you got that ass
cap you got that ask
good i'm good
okay i was like i've got a i've got a
dog bark in here for a minute too so
yeah um basically i just wanted to ask
one more thing uh what class do you mean
yes okay well d1 was uh was warlock
um most of d2 was hunter and i'm just
starting to play now
as titan okay i'm still playing a little
hunter mike like i guess my main is
still hunter
right all right so you lean hunter right
now yeah
i mean i like them all for different
reasons if i had time i would be playing
like
all of them all the way but you know
right now it's you're not an option
you're lucky enough to pick one
that's a big one exactly yeah i got to
sneak this in before you leave too it
refers to character
any favorite npc industry
oh yeah the sweeper bot
really appreciate the time you take we
we know how busy you are man
i mean babe what what an enlighting
lightning interview and just to hear
hearing the process and what you guys go
through
truly truly humbled to have you here man
definitely
a pleasure absolute likewise thank you
guys for having me i appreciate it
believe me it was ours maybe next year
whenever witch queen comes out we'll uh
rack your brain about uh what's going on
in the the world hopefully it's a
different state by then but
yeah but look man i mean like i said i
know you got these guys but um
what could i know obviously not on
social media but you know what can the
fine people look out for you in the
future or anything's got cooking
anything you want to promote
you know the floor is yours as far as
the team or anything you want to talk
about
yeah i mean i guess uh i guess i'm not
much of a promoter but like
if you like the game please keep playing
it and we love doing what we're doing
and we're having a blast and
you know otherwise i might be flipping
burgers so who knows
just just grateful about the soundtrack
so he doesn't flip burgers and y'all
nothing wrong with that i love cooking
hamburgers too
so hey a good burger is tasty but yeah
i'd say like seems like music is
it's very very clear that music is
something that is
like your passion for sure i mean it
comes through and
any interview i've listened to like the
way you describe what you do
um i would just say everybody in the
destiny community is very lucky to have
all of you and your team and everybody
at bungie we always can probably never
say thank you enough to all of you guys
thank you so much and right back at
everybody i mean we wouldn't be doing
what we're doing without everyone who
plays the game so
thank you guys much of frieza man thank
you for everything you do
a pleasure to have you what the destiny
music community and everyone that
appreciates what you got
like again this is tremendous man keep
up the fantastic work
and uh we we look forward to more
greatness as you continue on man
salute lord scott the legend
thank you thank
so we are back for part two uh skye had
to take off and
uh hang out with his family and
everything but now it is just cognito
and i your two co-hosts
hanging out talking about everything
that is beyond light and seasonal hunt
we were off last week so we've got a lot
to talk about so i have no idea how long
this part of the podcast is gonna be
but we got a lot of things to cover and
yeah cognito man how have you been
how's cognito been treating you i know
we had console lunches so you're a
little away but
you've been neck deep in it like 36
hours straight like chunks at a time so
how you how you feeling
what is what is everybody everybody
doing
yeah like um it felt so good finding the
last three days
to really grind you know the first week
like you said two consoles are out
didn't get a chance to play at all
because i actually policed myself
i said if i start destiny i have
literally a thousand dollars worth of
hardware in my living room that i'm not
gonna play
and that's not gonna happen so i need to
have some discipline
not launch destiny play everything else
xbox series x playstation 5 the games
and then right around monday i'm like
okay i got to get going
right this is you know i want to do
raise for worlds first
and i think the only thing i snuck in
the first week was the hey goliath
was that uh that's the the exploit on
the other shout out to that last sector
and uh the edz
shout out to the edz get to that soft
cap real fast 1200 oh got to that 12 20
kind of smooth
guys like yo i don't got much time so
let me least log in for this
so shout out to those that put me on to
that but yeah after that i didn't touch
it then monday i went back
but yeah this is what it's been man i've
been um you know doing the campaign
rocking out um narratively
let me just get some things out the way
yeah it's like just unload here we go
let's go narratively they're in a good
place
they are doing some things that are
truly amazing when we talked about
europa
you know things with the stranger
learning so much about lc
you know and just everything everything
with the with the falling and leading up
to
um aramis and stuff like that i thought
was very well done
you know i was i really i really enjoyed
the campaign i really did i felt like i
got a lot of backstory
on um fallen co elixie culture and stuff
like that we all knew eremis is gonna be
about it there but for the most part
thought that was cool and then leading
into you know
where we are now which is the uh the
hunt
and i didn't know how dire the situation
was without
he's in dire trouble i thought it was
okay put it this way when you sent me
the thing and you were teasing me and
you sent it for you said what biff had
said
like you know you guys got to stop
complaining that osiris got slapped and
stuff like that i guess i was i was one
of those guys that wasn't feeling that
after now doing that story
and then reading the lord have you read
the lore i haven't yet
i need to oh boy i mean i've seen people
crying so i know what happened but
so you you're up oh boy
okay so first off yeah there would be
a reason why he could be in that state
weakened and slapped by
anything running around him for him to
do what he did
so basically the long shorter is this
obviously when you start that mission
which is amazing you hear glenn you're
like yo who's clint i thought
if this is going to be what you call it
it's supposed to be pork poor pork i'm
like
what the hell is good okay cool you get
down there they like go to the moon
osiris is in trouble
okay cool then you hear
segura is dead what
that's insane so my man could catch the
final
death like no so i'm like oh this is
this is spooky right you need to go to
wait till you get the dark future look
yeah so i'm like oh this might be a cane
situation if we don't get down there
so you get down there now here's the
thing you do to save that we get to the
custody that we've seen and then
obviously aldrin comes out
fire and then uh the ultimate thing is
amazing
in the sense of what spider did spiders
says oh he's
he's a snake yeah i saw him wandering
around the shore and i didn't tell about
to tell him who he was and i've modified
his ghost and if he dare step over to
craft his ghost or whatever somebody
actually like some
i forget where it's either in discord or
one of my
probably haven't been streaming because
my internet sucks um no it was somebody
said like why is it
glint and not pulled pork i don't know
if you know i don't know if it was
somebody like made it up or there was a
reason but it was like glint
like i don't know if it was spider
spider always wants a ghost he's like
rotating him is like
his hand so it's like the glint in his
eye
somebody i don't know if that's like a
common theory or somebody said it or
wherever i saw that but it was like
why it's called glint is like it's kind
of the like spark in his eye or like you
know the
that thing that he like really desires
and it's like that glint that little
like startup like
and i was like that would actually make
sense is he kind of like modified and
had the ghost and
may have you know given it a neighbor
every bit glint it was like somebody
said that was like
if it's not true that's probably one of
the best things that makes sense for me
so i'm going to roll with that
yeah no absolutely i mean i think again
narrative why i just want to talk about
narrative first
and um now i know we got so much stuff
in the game but you know
the thing again after i didn't realize
how serious it was
so i got to take back my upsetness about
when i first saw the review
but when you read that law it's called i
think it's called imminent or something
like that yeah the one
with segera as an outline image read
that
it is powerful stuff so basically what
has happened in the long and short of it
is
you know when the plans start
disappearing you know stuff like that
osiris does go to zavala they are
communing
zavala's like yo i'm not sending you no
help for this threat you think you see
what you think is going on in the moment
we got europa to handle these are where
the resources are going
so osiris is like okay fine he goes
to get to drake man yeah that's what's
up so um he goes to um
the moon or whatever and come to find
out like i said there's evil rafting
they started hearing things the
supplicant all this stuff's going on
they venture down sagira is like i don't
know if we should do this
you're solo you're already weakened from
mowing around
i don't know if this is a good idea for
him he still goes he's like look we
don't get no help
he gets so deeper down into the moon
where he has the supplicant we have
crota's
children all in one area so
cyrus is like look i could get them all
out right now this is the opportunity
and the kid was like i don't know
like it's risky we should get called the
vanguard
he's like look i'm gonna take this shot
right now now here's the cool part
that's the part they don't talk about
that see everybody laughing remember
this the cool part law
you realize oh cyrus uses more than just
dawn blade
he used dawn blade nova bomb chaos reach
so he's killing mad hive
mad um crotis children all this other
stuff he's
almost at his goal but then this
i think they call it the supplicant of
something whatever this thing of zebra
is crazy powerful and then that's when
they get a hold of my man
and all of it stops so yeah dan
he's in trouble he's bound and now he's
about to get his light
sucked out of him right yeah so sagira
then
is like look both of them are like look
we're not gonna make this
right so in one of the coolest moments
he goes look tell saint
you know like bro stuff like this
like this when they actually attack do
the stuff that me and you complained
about
with this the bromance that should have
been talked about more because it
happens during the mission too
when osiris thought he was going to die
to god and saves him and he's like hey
tell
osir i mean tell saint this and then our
goal says no you tell him yourself
because we're going to save you you know
what i'm saying
but in the lore it's kind of a moment
between segura and sagira
and um osiris and um oh
basically he's like one of us not going
to make a live so then in like
matrix-like transformers fashion
seguira kind of does a we got to touch
[Music]
and like like just i don't know if she
like the way it was the way i read it
i could be wrong it felt like she did
some
move where i don't know if it's a
sacrificial kind of move
to eliminate the hive or whatever that
was going on from to help him escape
but at the expense of her own life so i
mean my only having not read it at all
my only comparison would be
what the traveler did to gaul yes
yes something along if you're saying
it's like she sacrificed herself she
used
the power of the light that was inside
of her yeah to defeat
what was in front of her but at the
sacrificial nature of herself but it
took that the traveler was bigger and
had enough and shattered but was still
kind of there and wounded and slowly
built itself back up which
it looks real smooth by the way now um
yeah that's what it sounds like she
sacrificed the power of her
of the light from the traveler that was
in her within her to save him
and it was uh the way it's so well
written
it's done shout out to new rad he
attribute that see
you read the law he uh now i feel good
about it i was like no he went out and
he's crazy weakened
i'm good with this but yeah sagara but
i'm gonna be real with you can i say
something then i'll give it right back
to you after all it's lost
sure i think this is a creative way
for bungie to say look because let's be
real we haven't
osiris been back for a while we haven't
heard the shakira voice actress for
a long time i by
inside baseball theory is that she's
either too busy because you know how it
is sometimes with these bungee
actors voice actors of what's actually
yeah it's the girl it's deadpool yeah
she's probably got a lot of stuff going
on she can't you know so they're like
look
we got to wipe his ghost out you know
i'm saying but i will say this it adds
depth to the story
and it makes him now vulnerable he yeah
he can get the final death now and last
question i gotta ask you does say
say you don't have a ghost no more
either right i honestly couldn't tell
you
i don't know i don't picture
i don't know if he ever like pulls the
ghost out but if he's still a guardian
doing what he does i would imagine he
just
he does but we don't i don't know of a
reference i don't know i'm cuz i i want
to say that there's three now
ghost lists you know eris
him now osiris and i was going to say
saying but anyway that's where i'm at
with the narrative
i know you wanted to let you go into
about what you've been feeling about the
game and i know we got gameplay
discussed so i want to talk about
quality of life things
but i just wanted to get that lore stuff
off because i read that
all the way yeah um so for me
first thing uh yeah they're doing
a much better job at storytelling now
sadly
aramis was exactly what we expected
she was the campaign boss now i will say
the campaign was longer than i expected
with the missions kind of the way they
handled some of that
but i will say the first thing that
started right
the story boarding when i booted up the
game
i lost my mind i was like thank you
yes that was probably my one of my
happiest moments to see them do that
type of storytelling because we just got
done playing ghost of sushima
that did that stuff very well kind of
explaining the demons and they did that
in this and i was so so excited about it
because you can't always afford to do
cinematics for certain things
but if they want to tell the story in
the game is a great way to do it
and that was like you got to see the
fallen without without their masks on
and you get to see their faces and the
four eyes and everything and i was like
the way they went through and explained
some of that stuff was so so good
um so that was like that that was
literally where it started for me i was
like well that's already a win so cool
um and then for me it was
a lot of europa beyond light the
stranger going through the story
kind of understanding what is going on
and you have what you're talking about
with osiris is like your big win but
it's like
i mean i bought the damn stranger statue
and we are getting more
information about her history so
how screwed up clovis is um
her relationship with her sister which
you spoiler
alert by the way for everything in case
that's not clear um
you get to see them two in the same
place you
actually get to see them next to each
other and anna can't take it
yeah she is not too thrilled as to why
it's like now elsie's
theoretic now if i'm reading if i've
gotten my story somewhat right
the stranger is the stranger from
another timeline not ours
yeah so like she knows elsie but it's
not the same one so somehow there's
another timeline clovis did the same
crap that he did before
but it's a different version and she's
seen
you know anna go down a dark path and
the darkness consume a lot of people and
like she's seen some
stuff to say the least and
like that was i thought that was a cool
way to be like hey here's a la sector
then you have the lore that she goes
into
the x like if you're gonna put lost
sectors in in
campaign they could not have done it in
any of a better way
like you work through you get to see
each of the lost sectors you kind of get
to figure out where they are
but then the best part was you just get
to turn around and you and then you get
to start
like talking at the end and i was like
hey i got this stuff then go back and
then you get more
like whoever did all the dialogue for
elsie did a
great job i think it's fantastic
as a voice actress yeah like she's a
she's carrying a lot of this weight of
this story
and i yeah i'm glad you mentioned
because i completely forgot to not talk
about that which was weird
but yeah those moments every time i go
into the uh what is it the bray research
facility
i look forward to that you don't get an
aspect or whatever it is like it's just
yeah continue here well done well done
yeah
so i mean my big focus has been her
because i think she's going to be the
through line because sadly
we had drifter and aerys hang out by the
little you know campsite for a little
while and then when you finish the
campaign they bail
yeah so our like you know shadow
vanguard
other three drifters back in the tower
and i don't know eris is probably back
on the moon camping out there like they
were out there for a bit doing her
little ball roll
which is fantastic she's a beast like
this she's a beast i love seeing harris
like
be awesome and fight and then elsa just
comes in shadow jumping
freezing everything she's sick like
she's i want her on my team but
um but yeah it's like so then
unfortunately it's like you get to see
everybody go back where they were and i
was like
that's kind of unfortunate yeah i kind
of figured they might be camping out
there and there might be more to it but
maybe that's stuff that develops later
i guess we'll just snooping on everybody
with that radio but continue
oh the radio yeah shout out to that oh i
went like every time there was a
campaign step like i got back to her and
she's like oh what about this and i
talked to her
talk to him listen to the radio every
time i was trying to get like the full
loop
um we figured out the what the weird
dramatic rotating
tar's ship was from interstellar thing
that's our like darkness interaction yes
yes and i kind of wanted to get your
thoughts on
the ghost like the way the ghost
was torn i don't know if you've played
enough where your post campaign
actually apologizes to you yes yeah so
like
the journey that your ghost throws
through in this thing is
quite like quite a journey of like i
don't know
zaval is still in denial which is we're
not gonna use the darkness anymore right
yeah right yeah he told me he goes
effective immediately your guardians are
not allowed i'm like i ain't giving this
up you
[ __ ] out here you got your minds
available continue
yeah i was like that one cracked me up
but no the journey that the ghost went
on through this one
shout out to nolan north of course
amazing performance
can we before we get to that kind of
about to go in are you gonna go into the
fun part
bro can you shout him out for the
drifter invitation
this is why bro this is what like listen
all
i don't know if there's anybody i don't
see dizzy in the chat all you did go by
this is why he's the greatest he the
range that he has now yes does he come
off whiny sometimes
but he apologized and you have a moment
like that mission where he's like i'm
gonna do my drifting
come on brother come on brother it was
yeah no that was
so good like so good that was one of the
most unexpected things during like there
was a lot of
that was one of the more like i was
surprised they went there i guess
because normally they're like kind of
serious with the tone certain things
there's not as much
humor without kade i agree but it's like
as
you know nolan north did like finish up
the cade wrap but it's like that was the
the tease at the fun that was nice to
see that was yes
a very hilarious way to end that one i
was i was like
i was pleased with that he he killed
that
he killed that but yeah you were saying
a reference to the ghost
what she was gonna say oh i think that
was mostly it just like the journey
because
you i i didn't even expect it later
because you go through and the jagos is
like
oh i don't know it's like in the
darkness stuff i don't know if i trust
us and you go through the campaign it
was just like a random time that i think
i drove down to the nexus
later and i think it just kind of
happens in there sometimes and it was
just like
the ghost apologized straight up to you
it's like i'm with you light
dark it doesn't matter i'm with you and
that was
i don't know what that does for lore if
our ghost because we have elsie that's a
that has her fish thing and again they
teased at some point that we may or may
not ever get one of those things
right because i know luke said it's like
you won't get one for a while and i was
like
yeah what the hell is that i mean yeah
one of those things but
generally it was what's your the
when the ghost actually finally kind of
came to acceptance of like light or dark
they're with you
and i don't know if the ghost isn't very
effective with dark because it's from
the light so i'm not sure if it's just
like i'm here for the journey what's up
right um so i'm just kind of curious to
see how that plays out if like
if in the witch queen if we do get a
second subclass and we have to embrace
more hive darkness stuff this time or so
however it goes down
right um i'm very curious to see how
that relationship with our ghost
progresses but i think they handled it
it was amazing this time through i
really enjoyed that part really enjoyed
again great job i didn't i didn't expect
that i thought
that you know it gonna be played it
straight narrow it's evil
don't touch it but you know and as it
went on he's just like look like you
said i'm riding with you you know we've
been on this journey together
i trust you you know what i'm saying and
i thought it was a cool moment and
to me it's just world building to what
we eventually i think we'll get to what
is it light fall or whatever
yep and and this is where we're going
and
you know we got to touch stasis yeah we
got to get straight into it
and um look you know
i obviously messing around with i didn't
know what to expect
you know and it was it was a bit of
getting my bearings about how the powers
work and stuff like that
as you go get the what is it the
fragments or whatever it is aspects and
fragments or later yep
the aspects of stuff like that so um you
know for me
i was really impressed with it i was i
was just like
let's talk about pv you know i was
i was really i did this this is
transformative stuff
like you know jumping in the air you
know warlocks shooting that thing i got
my freeze thing
and then just you got the op class to
start yeah
you got to tell me how to tighten this i
don't even i just know
i was just like this is ridiculous my
titan misses its melee so
i want to censor myself beep much it is
oh my titan
punch is it's it's i'm getting better at
the timing
but i still miss a lot there's a lot and
yours is you just shoot something
and they freeze i have to like i have to
hold it
kind of a release before i get there for
it to finish otherwise i go the wrong
direction or i pass it
or i'm too short yours just goes yeah it
just goes and then i mean
obviously we got the nerf that happened
a little bit today but it almost is
like um what the cool thing about it is
one thing why warlocks love top tree
dawn blade is the projectile melee also
on my belief another one
yeah also middle tree chaos reach yep um
like there's something fun about having
a melee you know say that's projectile
and that thing is really beastly
obviously i got the other
aspects and stuff for the um the other
grenades the cold snap
the other stuff too it's really it's
really powerful man and i'm starting to
get into the flow and even the super
itself frees them
one to freeze and then one to kind of
yeah yeah
and the radius of the massive massive
so you could freeze someone whatever go
around so i was doing that
um i really enjoyed that i will say
quality of life stuff things that there
were some things that
really stood out to me um one as a
person who specs
all the damn time having
all the damn grenade launcher heavy arc
void done having all the mods
yeah there's certain ones that are solar
arc and void still but
like doesn't matter which one i can do
machine gun sword grenade launcher and
pick that should have been from the
start and we all screamed that
from the raptors like it's been thank
you yeah thank you the scavenger perks
the all that stuff
then they did a little all the tweaks
and what i like though there's a little
one that no one i don't see when you
talk about
i like the minor intellect minor
resilient the 2.5
yeah so you can now spec really deep
spec and not waste everything i love the
fives those are an amazing addition we
all know
anti-barrier
they're all on the arms though yes all
of the arms oh yeah that was interesting
so just busted that out and bust out
ariana's vow
got unstoppable on it with the thing oh
somebody said in my chat do they
actually stack that's a good question
because i haven't i feel like somebody
don't they don't snack okay i gotta test
it because i haven't faced an
unstoppable yet yeah
i've done much champion stuff yeah i
just like the fact that exotics can come
into play you know what i'm saying once
again
yeah yeah artifact okay you know better
they at least they got rid of the middle
annoying yeah the first three columns
are all like weapon related there's like
yeah reloads dexter but that honestly
just tells me they don't know what to
put there
yes if you look at the artifact the
first one is your barriers those two
columns now
are like they're just all weapons
reloads dexterity for just a little
cheaper and i'm just like
that's not anything exciting it's like
it's just filler to get to the last two
functional columns yeah
we know what that is but i'll be like i
said i i like that aspect with the
builds
um not i mean i know i'll let you touch
weapons but what i wanted to touch
though what i thought is really cool and
i want to know how you feel about it
was i am a huge fan
of the exotic acquiring
change but as far as the lost sectors
solo yep i was like he's gotta love
because i think that's cool like oh no i
think it's fantastic
i haven't done him yet but i think it's
fantastic that gives i'm gonna tell him
tonight yes yeah the fact that the armor
has to come from there
yeah it makes you earn it thank you
thank you
hell yeah like many people earn the uh
like now
yes so the lost sector at 12.50 you can
max out at 12.50 you're the right level
you just got to figure out the champions
and once i get there i'll probably do a
guide over those there won't be too big
of a deal but
the fact that it's like i don't know
like some people
may hate the idea that it's a solo thing
but for there's a lot of people who
probably do play solo
and it's that thing that says if so low
and there's probably somebody in the
back of their head that's gone huh
and it's gonna change the way some
people think and have to go about it
but it's also a bit more of an
accomplishment because like if you got
that exotic
guess what you earned it you actually
had to do something to earn it as
opposed to
i log in here's my video
i i i think that's a very underrated
change and i i love it i want more of
that i like that it's
targeted to it it gave i think it's the
evolution of what lost sectors
should be right you know in the
beginning they were kind of feeling that
way and then they got a little better
then they got more expansive as
we got to shadow keep stuff like that i
think lost sectors are getting to that
point but when i heard about this
and that these joints are powerful and
then you have to solo it
i i really enjoy that i'm looking for it
i think today is the necrotic grip
i got to get in there because i'm going
for arms oh i'll leave that for my
wallet with the thorn and
i leave i've seen that combination that
looks ridiculous
and they let let's go so yeah that's
what i want to say with that i know
we'll get to the other things that we
don't like but i just want to focus on
the things i do like that i
i feel i like a lot of the new
not a lot of them but i like a lot of
the newer
weapons that i have seen um have you
gotten that fusion yet
uh yeah i've got it use that fusion bruh
i mean i've my role is trash i toyed
around with it a little bit
it has next to no i mean it's recoil it
was like it's
it's its own kind of thing yeah but it
was like my role was so trash i just
didn't really mess around with it too
much but it is like
it's really controllable somebody said
well i think somebody said it was like
more horizontal recoil it's
yeah it's very tight it doesn't feel as
strong
and i was like it doesn't feel like if i
go pull out a main ingredient
i feel like i can melt like multiple
guys and it felt weaker
so i've got to toy around with it more
maybe it was just like how like what
happened but it was like it
i still got a main ingredient which yeah
well gets all the other stuff but it was
like
that still felt like a fusion and that
one for some reason didn't feel
as strong and i don't know why maybe
it's like faster firing not quite
as high power i gotta get my hit and
that could just be me
for the little that i used it i don't
know so i'll just square it up
i got a perk i got a one for all perk
which is a damage buff i believe hitting
there's a three targets increasing
damage
that one it hits like a truck i'm i'm
literally using it to fight bosses i
throw a boss back on that
and i'm just melting things it's it's
really a good alternative when you run
out of heavy
so i've been having fun with that um i
believe
what else they got they got a lot of
cool the slug shotgun is really good i
felt
the new slug shot the duality the new
the exotic
not well that one's good i didn't get a
chance to play with it i haven't watched
i haven't played with it
at all i've been playing with it too
much because our people are running some
real sick builds with that
but there's a legendary the ones that
look like power tools all the power to
weapons
yeah i just don't know there's a slug
shotgun of those is there yeah it's
it's a there's a um it doesn't look like
a just because the shape is different
damn what's the name it's um bone
chiller apparently oh that sounds about
right oh yeah
it's a void it's a void one it's avoid
one
yeah that one hits hard too i've had fun
with that well i mean those got that
like buff a while back in pve or if you
can hit that crit it's gonna hit hard
yes it's just like you gotta go risk
reward to go get up close and at that
point
yeah i've been having fun with that and
i like a lot of the new perks i like
the pulse shocking right i know which
one would you do
um of course i'll pull up dim and find
out
but this is one of those things if you
ever think somebody doesn't know what
they're doing in a podcast just try and
remember everything
good luck on the spot yeah it's not
gonna happen um hailing confusion
yes it's good it's well i got serp okay
so there are new perks
yes so i got surplus and wellspring
on my hailing confusion the surplus
increases handling reload speed and
stability for each fully charged ability
wellspring kills with this weapon
generate ability energy are you
serious that's my role that was my first
what's the first one what's the first
part
so the first one is increases handling
reload speed and stability for each
fully charged ability
wellspring kills with this weapon
first part uh surplus surplus
okay so you got surplus and together
the energy is divided between your
uncharged abilities so if you only use
your grenade
it's going to charge that one faster
than the splitting between all of them
fire
that is amazing yeah i like that joy it
is um another post look out for
stars and shadow if you didn't get that
one
i i've used it but my perks again
haven't been as good i don't know what
the perks on it are
it's a 340 what's the other one three
it's nineties
the hailing confusions like that's like
my that's like my go figure type
i don't know that's you i already know
you that you already find a hole with
that for me
i'm in such this cold denial bag but i
even feel this one aims
that archetype is very underrated that
aggressive frame pulse
they are really beast in pve so the only
thing is like the perk pool and stars
and shadows insane they come with all
these different perks it's
it's immense but um it is a really
good solid just need a little bit
stability but it's a solid pulse
the aim now sights is even better too
but yeah i've been liking i've been
liking those legendaries i've been
dropping the
the few that do that we've had
we'll get there the new thermal erosion
the machine gun
which is a whole different talk when it
comes to loot because it's the only new
machine gun but you need a machine gun
to get machine gun kills you're like
wait a minute what if i'm a new player
yeah whole different problem we'll get
to the loot here in a minute but that
one is just like that is
900 rpm bullet holes just
you know what to me i look at it like
okay delirium
this you're going to fit my delirious
spot that's basically
is just a bullet hose delirium just kind
of switched over
now i will say let's go i've been
leveling up my other one but no time to
explain feels
good too good
have you got the have you uh finished
the catalyst got the catalyst
whoa all right haven't you done double
buddy have you done double buddies yet
because i can't but you gotta tell me
how double buddy is i'm gonna do it it's
just that i'm so
in love with stasis it's hard for me to
take stasis off and then
places a whole topic for discussion yeah
i mean like yeah no time to explain you
can finish what you want to say there
but it's like we're going to come right
back to what you said first you know
first of all again that archetype i
believe no time i believe it's the same
as cold denial that that's a 340.
yeah 340s right now hit like a truck
so great for boys db and what i like is
you can build up with the headshots or
anything but it's actually easier
to dps you know majors and then get the
buddy
keep getting the body and keep extending
the body hit
it's on precision hit you just smack
your soul something yes
but yeah it's so good oh my god i love
that thing that thing is aggressive
it hits hard that little little buddy
yeah
man no time to explain is is very
impressive i'm looking at my outbreak
perfected like damn where can i find a
way for you to put you back in the mix
because i'm not that's
yeah it's just no time it's just like
for the little buddy though it's what's
on screen because they're getting
something just off and until you turn it
on
they did that purposely because when you
do get away artists getaway artists is
the opposite
get away artists who snitch anything
around you yeah even if you don't have
field of view
they kind of nerf this in a sense that
yeah like you say it has to be
your exact field of vision if it doesn't
if you don't see it
it don't see it that which is fair
but yeah i'm gonna run double buddy i
want to see how that goes but it's very
i gotta worry about double buddy is but
yeah it's like that was one that i was
like
and all they did is just give it that
little extra but it was like it just it
feels good
in the meta right now now i will say one
this is just a small little tip because
i forgot about it till somebody probably
mentioned it in chat
as a titan i need melee kills for things
yes and as i miss a fair amount with my
stasis melee i suck at it for a while
you can i can't well new red said he
eated himself off more things than he
knows what to do with just
trust me but also like now you cover a
lot of ground
to a point like you can actually travel
pretty far but it's like the timing of
it oh dude like
the first the first time you ever jump
on a tight and be like i like i get my
stasis stuff
oh i gotta use this mail what the f is
that like you're gonna feel like you
don't know how to melee things anymore i
promise
you because everybody else i've seen is
like yeah this melee is rough
monte carlo is the nice counter for me
to be like oh i screwed up my mail
okay let me try that again i forgot
about that for so many different things
and somebody said it i was like about
monty
you're absolutely right why do i not use
that gun more i'll be forgetting that i
literally i was like i pulled it out of
collections and i was like
i have enough melee things that i need
to punch between different activities
and stuff then i was like
yep i'm gonna use it and i've been using
the living crap out of it so if you need
the other one if you need super kills
bad juju don't forget about that as well
so there's two
there's not a lot now i also notice
there's a perk when it comes to my
wonderful grenade launcher
called thresh killing combatants with
this weapon generates a small amount of
super
energy and then another one i got is
called chain reaction
each final blow with this weapon creates
an elemental damage explosion
on a grenade never got that one heavy
grenade launcher
basically picture uh
why do i forget the name of the stone
graviton lance the cosmology
explosion it's that level it's that
or pretty cool it's probably not quite
the catalyst like over op version
yeah but it's like explode explode like
you get a double explosion with a
grenade launcher you do one
which one does it roll on which grenade
launch did you have it's the crowd
pleaser
um is that void one yeah it's the void
one yeah yeah
yeah i got that i got it but mine's got
thresh so i don't got that i haven't
seen that other
fight grenade field prep thresh that
i've been using
well okay here's another one you got
chain reaction i also got one with
killing wind
mm-hmm that's what i got i got killing
wind and thresh on my crowd pleaser
that's crazy wow wow lovely
new perks man yeah it's like so there
are some new perks for creativity you
notice
none of them are rampage kill clip
related yes
they at some point want that stuff gone
gone my
rampage uh subsistence uh gnawing hunger
is still gonna be my auto rifle all the
way up until season 15 and then at some
point i'm
gonna force me to get rid of it but for
now it's good
um i will also say whenever you need to
clear ads
oh my trinity my trinity goal
dude that catalyst has made that thing
so good
so like like you get one kill just
lightning light lightning
lightning lightning lightning i'm like i
love it there's two
there's two requirements now i get
excited when they tell me the game when
i'm for bounty
one is arc right with that i'll dust off
that that trinity ghoul
yo sunshine is still it man say i
haven't
actually used that since everything came
back on i haven't used it yet
please you said shot you're good gonna
you're gonna you gotta just smile
endlessly
with the ridiculousness of that it is
the chain reaction it's insane
it's it's it's almost i would say
slightly better
than um graviton because those are the
three as far as i feel with
getting really um ad clearing
um elemental kills easy sunshot for
thing
what you call it uh trinity ghoul for
arc and then um what you call it um
graviton is still uh a lot of people are
also going to run risk runners the other
one too yeah risk weight is really good
i mean you also get that shield against
a whole lot of fallen stuff so
gives a double benefit so i mean it's
like they're
it's weird that like old exotics like a
lot of these are quite old
um they're getting kind of a fresh life
to them yes
yes it's like just kind of goes to show
that they need to do that to more stuff
but
yeah so let's talk about have you jumped
in a
pv there sir yeah i've been playing a
fair amount of glory to try and get all
those wonderful powerful drops because
they're the best place to do it so many
powerful drops oh shout out to the
destiny show
salute brothers a character the great
dress tonight go ahead and can't wait
oh man yeah skye was amazing thank you
brother really
really appreciate it man we got to work
with you brothers and get that collabo
going with the last word you already
know
but um yeah man um yeah pvp
let's talk about it well i mean things
change
today this episode's like totally out of
order so don't hold a chance that this
one's gonna be uh
anything but just a weird order of
things but yeah we got a
we got a nerf yeah yeah nerf
to the warlock warlock warlock where
like
well like look oh
before before we get into the nerves i
just want to talk about my experience
when i first do this thing
how how cause i didn't get to play it i
only got to face it
okay how was that all right so i get it
i was terrified to jump into pvp i saved
it for the very last pinnacle
right of the of that prior reset
slightly all right all right i did
everything gambit's done
which i like shout out to gambit quick
and busy fun
no well cuz like a couple of the two
fragments i had like
because i've seen fragments for
strikes where you have to kill champions
with stasis now granted a tassie said
you can kill those with um
finishers while having the stasis class
equipped and it still counts
but i don't want to kill 10 you have to
kill finishers
with stasis i'm like the timing of
having the ability up
in a strike versus with random people
you're like what the hell is that
keep killing the joint
yeah i don't and and the crucible is
killing people with stasis as well
bro so i didn't gambit
the one where you got to use slowed
or crucible kills that is the
worst i hate that with a passion and
it's like
18 kill i'm like come on man it's brutal
it's brutal
but um yeah do what you say so i didn't
i don't start distract whatever get to
this there i'm like all right wait what
the hell's going what happened in here
that's pvp so i get in there
and eat i'm not gonna afraid when you do
this to someone
it is the funniest thing ever like
somebody was aping around the corner
they just had that
that that fell witness they ready to
slide shotgun stop
it's disrespectful so i said oh my god
this is
open like it it was so busted that i'm
like
oh bungie don't care no more they just
sit the hell about they just said you
know what
pvp is gonna be mayhem we're gonna let
you guys run rampant
it's just hilarious like that first
prior pre-nerf
my main thing is now when it happened to
me i was oh i don't like this
that's just what it is then on top of
that you gotta hold it down for so long
i was like i knew two things i said
it's too long in the freezing state you
know
then you're losing so much health and
i'm just like
yeah yeah so i'm just like nah they
gotta and again we'll get to what they
did and dress with that
and warlock super bro
this thing is so out of control yeah
yo i literally circled the map two times
looking for people
the meter goes down so slow i was oh my
god
god let me really just do this okay yeah
it was worse than nova warp in this
prime i was like yeah this this this
is gonna get shut down quick but i have
my fun
i have my phone for a little bit i will
say 30 seconds long
yeah i will say though
as scared as i was for pvp
and yes there there's still there were
some issues
it makes you think different oh yeah
it changes the sandbox in a way
that i knew those certain things were
overpowered but i will say like
lest i say i'm enjoying it
that's the big debate for a lot of
people right now is you have
how balanced can pvp ever be that's one
question that's always going to be tough
it also depends on if they can ever
truly balance like hey does the warlock
melee in pvp
travel this far and pve travel this far
like how much can they balance that
stuff
but on the other side you have some
people stasis may be like an easy button
for some people but it's they're also
having fun
um i mean shout out to you know caccus
and podcast it was him tashed and true
vanguard
those three are you know they're
definitely pretty elite players up there
for all the stuff that they do
and it's like and they feel for both
sides it's like yeah the warlock is op
but there are some people that finally
feel like they're having fun
i was like and it's hard to balance that
so
it's like some people are saying the
warlock got nerfed so make sure you play
your feedback
more of the changes were done against
guardians yeah
so that's good because like the cold
snap freeze duration lowered from
four and a half seconds to one point
three five seconds that's
big that's like come on that's like
three hundred percent less
yeah that's same thing ice flare bolts
freeze so like your freezing time is so
much lower by the cold snap
the ice flare which is i guess is your
melee no penumbra what is ice flare
ice flare that might be your st your
super attack
because you have my motorcycle is the
melee yeah
the winter's wrath heavy attack no
longer affects players who are not
encased so basically that's
the poof i believe yeah that's the poof
but then like i guess your bolts i guess
are the
the duration of those is all short but i
mean you're going 4.75 seconds
to 1.35 seconds that's not small
that's three and a half damn seconds
like how's
how was that where it started and that's
where they adjust it like that's
where they just like let's see how
busted it is we're gonna change it by
like three quarters less like that's a
large
shift to do quickly by the way normally
they wouldn't do something that big that
fast
so i mean i guess we'll see where it all
kind of bounce maybe this is the big
lower
and then maybe they bring it up a little
bit if people say it's too weak
right no i think it had to happen i
think this is two
one because obviously when you put it to
about i think the um
world's first was obviously in jeopardy
i mean that with the warlock super being
broken and
and melting bosses they had to address
that so i'm glad this stuff happened
but i've been playing a lot of pvp and i
have to say this is all fair i think
the issue we think why i think why they
got it so wrong
is because in pve it feels right to hold
them in place that long
right but in pvp no bro like i i'm like
it's too long and you're penalizing me
for breaking out so to me it should be
if you are successful in freezing
someone
you got one or two seconds to get it
done otherwise
let the person free and now they're
tying it to higher resilience
and stuff like that to balance that
because you got you should have
it's a two-part process doing it and
then capitalizing
now i feel it's a little fair i can't
wait to actually go in there
uh tonight and and try it out to see how
it feels now but
i felt i felt it was fair i i felt what
i wrote everything i've read i was like
yup that's a good nerve yeah that's good
i mean
that's everybody that i know was just
like yeah it's busted we gotta fix it
and this is probably the fastest they've
done these things which also goes to
show how quick they can change some
things
hope now and how good that quickly like
i told you guys
the warlock supers and the hunter supers
get nerfed with the quickness whenever
we run out of control those titans you
guys get a little business
shout out to you cactus i saw that uh
response that you put out to you
i just donated anyway but i mean granted
trust me like ours is okay but it is
this is a very very different feeling of
everything that you do with stasis the
way you freeze it the way you shatter it
uh the aspects the fragments the
subclasses and all this does is set up
the question when the hell is it gonna
happen to the rest of the classes
yeah like the customization now we're
getting the fragments to change up your
abilities more and do these different
things
and even if it's just like now do you
think they're gonna like
completely like revamp the classes
that's why it's going to take them a
little while or would you just rather
see like
hey do it now just like shuffle up
what's in there and put them aspects
fragments and give me my stuff like
would you rather see it quick
or would you rather see them go deeper
into
you know now your rift freezes stuff
what would the warlock fire
rift like maybe it said what am i
getting there by the way i've been
waiting for that's the one i want badly
i want that so bad where does that come
well that's the big question of what now
we're
like okay so we got our story we started
hunt
and now we have hit all all of the time
gating walls that are everywhere you
have the aspects
we have one we logged in no new aspect i
could get fragments but i have one
aspect there's a lot of those
there's varrics yes
he didn't have more stuff to unlock he's
waiting on more information
and i'm sitting here just accumulating
these here whatever they're called
things yeah seals
yeah um so i'm like
when are those coming there's no
expectation of like
i thought it was gonna be a weekly like
progression across that line but
or maybe if i unlock no you just hit all
of them and you're done you're like
mm-hmm
okay why yeah yeah yeah
time gaining this there's definitely oh
there's no dancing around it we do we
know what this is
well that's the other thing is now the
time game's just me oh you log in
there's new stuff bye bye bye bye bye
i'm just gonna buy everything as soon as
like it's open cause i'm gonna have so
many of those things by the time i'm
done
it's not gonna be that big of a deal um
but yes just like the time gaining of
some i'm one like we know the seasons
what like three months long
yeah so maybe next week we'll see in it
but it's like if you do that
you're gonna take almost the whole
season to unlock all of stasis
esp with the aspects at least now the
fragments will be sitting there and
they're on every class but the aspects
yeah they're gonna be slow they're gonna
be slow i mean
i guess i'm torn because you know
yes do i want all the toys yeah i want
all that you know what i mean
i just think again it's just i'm not
trying to kind of defend them for
everything it's just like
they're in a tough spot with that
because it's like
you give it you give it to us all of it
you know what i'm saying and then
like this is what i feel i feel
sometimes bungee this is why i think
bungie does good sometimes i think
sometimes
i like when they try to force us to just
mess with a certain
couple of things first only because i
think us as the hardcore we tend to look
at what's the most effective first so
we'll see we'll have all these things
and we'll be like okay this is more
effective than that but then there's
times where there's stuff that i feel
like mercury said that we had on like
that are that are really good
but they're not really given a shot
because they were launched along
something else that may be slightly
better that everyone's using as the meta
i'm okay with the aspects and all that
stuff being drip feed
i don't i agree with you though with
varix
i didn't necessarily i didn't feel good
that his stuff is grayed out and i'm
sitting on this currency
and i can't you know what i'm saying
like that part felt weird
well and it's like that's
counterintuitive to the crow when you
can unlock it
yes right that's the difference that's
the difference like there's no
i guess it's just not consistent at that
point because you can unlock his stuff
i saw somebody had it done in like an
hour and i was like holy jesus
i'm like about six ranks in or something
like that
fyi if you guys are doing those little
the hunts yeah when you go to pick your
like the prey yeah if it says recon do
it because it gives you like 17
instead of four or five oh i didn't know
that yeah but yeah go dig
through because normally you'll start
with two and then when you unlock hive
you'll have all four
if ever you have the option to pick the
recon data
and you're leveling him up do that
because instead of four or when you get
the first one it goes up to five
right it's like 17 for one of those
instead and you're almost done with the
whole rank right then i'm like
yeah so just fyi how how are we feeling
about the hunts
it's like monster hunter uh
hold no i'm trying to think of the right
reference here um
monster hunter like natty light
yes it's so watered down monster hunter
it's not even funny
here's this thing weaken it chase the
blood trail bam bam done
like there's not there's not really
mechanics to him there's
shoot the green dude stay in this thing
and half of them i know i did find a
tier two took me a little longer
um but the tier one uh
yeah yeah that like because i keep i was
running around the fusion rifle for a
little while
stand in there about seven shots when
they're done yep
like and that's one of those where it's
a shooter
sure and i'm sure there's gonna be tier
two which takes a little bit more like
effort and play to the area and i had to
play things a little bit slower
um they're short and sweet which isn't
bad
they're a way i like they are short
for grinding for specific things yeah
you want to go for a piece of armor
for a chest that has highest that role
specialized in intellect you can do that
that's
really specialized now when people run
out of stuff they need
and you still have to do that for sorry
hiccup mm-hmm
um and if you when you run out of the
stuff you need
and then you have to go do them you're
going to be like oh yeah after that
and it's five of them right for the for
the drop i think we got to do five
five for the drop if you get to the
third rank box
yeah it becomes a pinnacle so don't pick
up your powerful
until you can sit there and like go to
him hit escape to go past or whatever
your back button is
to skip the pickup and then when you get
the third upgrade block
it gives you four powerfuls instead of
two okay and then his
bounty challenge turns into a pinnacle
oh wow
okay okay so that's why that's going to
be worth doing as well so yeah skip it
for a little while because the pinnacle
also is going to be a thing and then
here's a giant thing in the room
what's up there's a few bugs in this
game right now dude
some things going on with some things
things happening
i was like now granted they hotfix
probably the biggest one the boss
breaking like doing 18 billion damage to
a boss with
stasis overload fun but i mean you have
pentacles that weren't working you have
lost sectors that they deactivate you
have weapons that weren't working you
have
a lot of things not all
but some would definitely get in the way
of like raid prep
yeah yeah yeah it was it was spooky for
a little bit
you know um you know i mean i'm not used
to
this level from them but times are
changing
by yourself times are changing yeah
times are changing for one but
two like you've noticed like kind of the
crispiness of the game like the new
falcon
vulcan api and stuff like i know that's
got to be part of it now granted the
game's pretty
like it's you can tell the difference in
like the visuals
how's the cosmodrome look dude have you
oh that was amazing
that was amazing i logged in there i was
like
oh this feels right that like that's one
of those points because now we're on pc
60 frames decent like
like everything like you know settings
are cranked pretty high for our displays
and stuff
that is probably what i look like the
ps4 d1
that's like that's like going back to
play the remake of zelda
is what d1 probably looks like on ps4
compared to what it looks like with the
new api on pc
like that's the difference in my head
and you know we forgot one thing i
forgot about this
how we not gonna talk about how amazing
europa is aesthetically when it comes to
the snow build-up oh dude when my spirit
girl blew away
i lost my i lost it i was like wait
where's my
i thought i was i thought my controller
my mouse i thought something was broken
i was like why can't i drive what is
and then i just sat there and my
sparrow's blown away i'm like are you
okay
it's amazing then looking at the
individual footprints that you make
in the snow you know what i'm saying
visibility dampening when it get when
it's night and it's hard to see
like the engine yo if they're gonna cook
up this stuff
and put it involved and bring it back
with these type of effects i'm about
that man
i'm about that because congratulations
to the next weather system you want
like one they took away like honestly an
easy one would be like thunderstorms on
titan
would have been like beautiful with this
system
what do you want to see next because the
weather on europa makes sense it's a
giant blizzard
but what would you what would you ask
what would be number two
trying to think of all the planets that
that we got that would make
sense for some type of i mean because
even what you call europa has the
daylight cycle right
yeah it gets started day night cycle
yeah new rap mars sandstorm will be fire
i like that yeah i like that i can do
that i can do a sandstorm on that
but um yeah man i mean listen they're
killing it they
get with the engine with with um
cosmodrome with with europa
and europa is massive like let's not act
like
no europa's gotta be they could lose a
little they could use the landers on the
top though for the love of god put one
up there
yeah just yeah it can't be that hard
just
drop me somewhere just in that because
it the campaign made it so much worse
go up there every single phrase
i'm about to throw up on this elevator
right come on
yeah yeah yeah it is massive yeah both
oh they said volcanic panic storms on
venus
see venus would be a pretty planet to
bring back now venus would be
so pretty i remember taking pictures of
that scan of the
of the skybox on venus with like the
blue lava running down the volcano in
the background
dude i took so many pictures of that yes
not even funny it's
so pretty but no what i was doing
actually i was sitting at
uh whatever that place is called beyond
and then i went to go probably get one
of my aspects and i jumped up on the
little
ship that dove itself into the snow and
i'm looking out toward the pyramid ship
kind of getting a wallpaper pic of me
barely there kind of in the in the
pyramids in the background
i'm in my menu changing my settings i
come out
and i can't see five feet in front of me
and i'm like
where the hell did the pyramid oh that's
the weather it was like yes
that was one of like i mean you see it
blow in and you kind of get you know
it's close but that was like
crystal clear picture can't see sh
can't see anything nothing shout out to
shadow prices
so he's like oh venus was amazing yeah
we know
that's your favorite location to be
where shout out to shadow pricing there
but
yeah man i'm with you like it's just so
many cool things about like i said
aesthetically
the time they put in the weather system
all these different things to create
that environment and i just love going
into the
the abandoned facilities and and and
getting the law
and getting the music like when we have
sky on like just talking about i love
the themes in there
and clovers are like a sick dude all
this stuff we reading and
it just really does it's it's really
well done
and i gotta shout them out on that the
only thing now that you know a little
bad obviously
it's a sun setting are we going to the
negatives now we're going to the we've
been
we've been spraying our sunshine all
over this thing yeah we gotta talk about
it man
um seeing some things come back uh
what'd you feel about that
no i was like i think i texted you while
while i was going through it and you
asked me as like what are your thoughts
and i was like
campaign great something's good one of
the first drops i got and also one you
get in the story
were a giant glaring example of why it
did not feel good
one was the long shadow from varrix
that one is in the wrong place
a vanguard put the new pulse in there
put
put any of the new power tool blue and
red weapons from barracks
i don't care but that long shadow
sitting right there is like what are you
doing there
why why are you there but that was one
the one that hit me worse which was when
i got a
scorn armor plate as one of my first
drops on europa
yes that's the one that burned me that's
the one that burned me the most i'm like
what the hell is this doing on this
planet why is it even why is it even
here like i
no like this is two expansions ago this
is yes related to the scorn i mean talk
about taking me out of like my
taking me out of you know the zone there
of destiny is like
i did not like i honestly just did not
i saw the score and i was like no no no
no get out of my inventory i don't want
you there i was like
that did not feel good i'll be
completely honest i that was bad
so yeah no it was like i mean sunsetting
is one of those were
i mean yeah sunsetting needed to happen
to some extent we all can kind of
understand there are things that needed
to happen
apparently their sunsets and planets too
but yeah what's up justin thank you for
the sub appreciate that the title is
that the titan
but like that like when we're seeing
just the the world loot pool didn't get
much of a change
right and the sun setting is still like
now
they're almost backtracking it partially
which we'll talk about as well which is
a thing
and you're like okay so the sun setting
works
right if you fill the holes you take
away exactly
exactly and i knew this was going to be
one of the biggest hits
to everything it's the most strikes that
ever leave it's the most
weapons that will ever go because now
we're going to be building stuff over
the course of a year
right but we lost so much and it doesn't
feel like we got
much at back yeah we lost a lot it you
you know what it's telling
when you get bounties and you're like
hold on do i even have that weapon
archetype anymore
that's all machine guns the prime
example take a new player
if they don't have thunderlord yes and
they don't
have the gun from the empire hunt
there's literally a bounty they can't
even do there's not one in the game
yeah that that's a problem and um yeah
like you say
if you don't have that if you don't have
if you don't have what you could share
by the way at some point they are making
that toaster though
the actual toaster life mm-hmm
uh if you don't have xenophage which is
not easy to get
nope thunderlord you know what i'm
saying and then a lot of the other stuff
has been sunset like or the seventh
series which they can't get
what they can't get right now coming
soon but come so so again it puts them
in
a background so yeah the sun said listen
long-term
yeah i know i wasn't for it in the
beginning but long-term yes i think the
legendary thing
will probably be the right move but
they've got to
right now we're feeling it because they
took so much away
and it's not enough back so it's like
they're gonna have to start each
subsequent season like really
reintroducing a lot of stuff
now they were on the right path with the
um the i'm just gonna call them
the red and blue power tool weapons
they're unique like they're they're cool
i don't mind them
i actually like a feeling of those maps
yeah yeah i like a bunch of them and
stuff like that but yeah that that is
the glaring thing
right now that they've they've got to
get a hold of and each we we need to see
more
and then i think it's a time getting
yeah the time gaining
definitely hurry up and wait hurry up
and wait you know with certain stuff
we see that they trying to you know do
the stretching thing i'm gonna give it a
pass obviously this week we got the
world's first
getting ready for that you know what i'm
saying i know that's a big deal for them
the promotions out there and all that
stuff
but i'm curious to see also how they're
going to do it but
all right let me give them some credit
though i did like logging in tuesday
and getting that cinematic and getting
that level i love that
i like this the narrative ties in
yeah have been really amazing so far
from start to finish they really kill
him with that so if they can if they
keep
this one i feel like the gameplay stuff
is still
a little behind on certain things but
the narrative team
they're on fire right now like they are
lit like this is the type of destiny i
want
all the time like i'm going to get
addicted to this i need this all the
time now
logging in find a cinema cool special
mission
let's go that's where i'm at are you
are you going to get yourself a parka
for the cold times up there
say man if i watch i'm going to get i'm
gonna be in there on saturday with the
squad hey
i get a [ __ ] i'm going for it i'm going
for it well that's like usually just
like i think it's through december first
so you have like a week and a half to
get that one a week yeah i'm saying will
you buy
the parka oh yeah come on man i gotta
have a trip okay i gotta have my
warlocks
you know that's a word that doesn't even
come out of my mouth in that sense just
drip oh my god
you gotta get that drip gonna throw the
hood on you know say i gotta
i am so not hip it's not fun like
literally couldn't up nope
you gotta get that drip if i
said that sentence i could probably not
sound wider if i said that sentence
i would give i would give you some key
words man we gonna start flowing what
happened
he's gonna be flowing like who the hell
are you my wife is like
justin just fell out of this chair he's
like oh dude i can't even
shout at the dead he said you suck your
hair here you're hit by association
my street
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
and not hip it's like were you ever cool
i don't think i ever was and i
definitely am not now
so that's how that goes so saturday
right yeah i'm going for it man that
definitely it's gonna be fun
well i like the fact that i'm actually
of light
to compete like i i like alexa i was
gonna say what did you think of the
grind
oh let's see um the beginning camp
oh i actually liked it in the beginning
because i felt
the campaign outside of me doing the
hustle with the
loot cave 2.0 did you get to play it
normal before you hustle
i have not so what this is why i like it
because
if i didn't it was kind of punchy in
there yo
it was connor oh no i died plenty
i liked that and then you know campaign
felt leveled right playing normally
the campaign felt love felt like that's
the first time because
normally we just smack them around in
the campaign it's not
it's at a point where what's that it
wasn't aramis remember when you beat
aramis
and then the other chicks kicked me yes
but
bro that's frustrating my brother was
like dude i hate this chick i'm like i
feel you i died a few times that chick
was
she had me under so much pressure there
was a time when i was trying to run
around the map
she would freeze me in mid air and i
would fall
like a cinder block into the thing
i said i was bad but i was like this is
good it's challenging i i gotta
work i gotta think i was like they gotta
miss though man they don't
freaking miss you're like peeking out
from cover on the other side and be like
yes
nah you're stuck what's the boss that
you fight
i don't know where it's at the facility
and
he's got like these little circular
things you got to shoot all over the map
before you break his shield he's a good
encounter too
i forgot what um general that is
basically
you know i like this oh the um yeah the
one basically in what looks like the
deep stone crypt or the
yeah science facility i phallics i think
yeah yeah yeah yo technocrat
is a dope fight what you call it is a
good fight um the hoverdrill yeah shout
out to daniel shout out to
prescott absolutely like i love the fact
that they were
in seoul over there like i really had to
work i really
died and i was like damn it i got to
start this boss fight over i'm like i
got to take this serious because
as you said we're used to just just kind
of knocking stuff
off like it's not that big and i was
like playing it about the right level i
was like oh oh
oh damn it's like and you then you
realize and that's where the freezing
when you freeze and then you break out
and that's where it is like
you are destified of the floor that cold
snap grenade that they have like
catching you're like you see it coming
you're like no no no wait
you want to go off the ground is it me
or are these falling a little extra
aggressive with them spears
and and roughing you up oh yeah they
they kind of crank some stuff up
feels like i mean it feels like yeah
i'll be trying to jump away they three
and i'm underneath and they come i'm
like yo they are
very aggressive i like it though i'm
just saying i just know that i'm like
were they this aggressive in the past
like i i definitely felt uh an up in a.i
and two oh don't think we need to
mention shout out
to the two new enemy types really a big
fan
we got our big leggy leggy harpy yay
lanky harvey
and then the metal gear brother the
little the mini scores of the pass
now here's the question the leggy harpy
yes i want to hear you say that
i i can't even how do you even pronounce
it no here i'll
i'm going to say wyvern it's not bad
it's wyvern but yeah it's pretty simple
okay
yeah no i've heard some goofy ones on
that so yeah
the wyvern but yeah the brig is just
like yeah those guys are frustrating
because you can't crit them until you
pop the hat the face
and then finally like at that point
you're like oh now i'm gonna melt you
but for a while you're just pissing me
off
especially when you're in i think it's
cadmus ridge on the west side
and the random one that roams that dude
has so much health
kind of just die dude it isn't me as i
don't like the sound that thing makes it
makes me very uncomfortable
it's like these weird
okay they have some powerful you got the
dropping missiles from above
you got the shooting like the bomb
explosion that goes
but yeah i will definitely say the
wyvern have yeted me off a few ledges as
well yes
they jump up and they're like oh i'm
fine and they they catch you and you're
like
yes love though i like new
enemy types and it's really good your
chat is on fire
yeah in fact with the clicking noises i
was like what did you pyro could not get
off of that on twitter by the way pyro
what do you think of the click
it's his charm yes
i don't know it just it's barracks it's
he's just
weird and creepy and weird when he talks
just basic stuff it's
like i just i just like it i just think
it is inherently
foolish and creepy and that to me is
what varricks would do very
he's something he's like get him an
inhaler he's like
it even says it because i have the
subtitles on
and it's like you got the insect noises
like and then he's like when he wheezes
he's like
and he like he'll wheeze and you're like
dude come on he's just like struggling
over there
he's so uncomfortable like everything
about him is
uh it just adds i mean he's a sleazy
opportunistic
now three-armed fallen guy with like
chain mail over his little mount
and dude just take the mail off like
don't breathe through the middle
shut up the bags from being sleazed he's
just a funny guy he's a dude he's just
like oh help me no aries don't freeze me
and all this stuff and
side note how are we feeling about on
salvation's grip outside of using it for
my frat like the crystals that i had to
go shoot
it doesn't feel that great okay i
thought it was just me because i'm like
i don't know if anybody's enjoying it or
maybe it doesn't feel like
i mean or the charge is too long to get
the big benefit out of it maybe
but i'm like but even then it's like i
feel like the wall is more effective
yeah i'm like i'm freezing i'm like okay
then what i mean are you getting a cr
you get crit damage whenever
you're shot shooting i was like i
haven't honestly used it that much
because it didn't feel great in the
first place prescott i'm with you
i just don't know what the point like
i'm like well maybe it's a gameplay
mechanic that i haven't seen yet
that like i understand like the warlock
super or
whichever i just have a question are
there other stasis
things in this game that's what i'm
saying because it feels like it's
incomplete right it feels like okay i do
this
and then something else is supposed to
do something else like how the the
warlock super is you know i shoot them
off freeze them and then i do my gandalf
i do my laundry
like almost have ultra handling on
because you shoot it and then have to do
something else
yeah it's just i'm like what what am i
the stage the stage to acquire it was
was dope shout out to the ghost
drifter it was an amazing stage amazing
state
and that imitation was hilarious and but
once i got it i'm just like
i i literally got all the things and i
promptly threw it in the vault
after i yeah it didn't feel great
while i i was using it during the
missions and stuff where i kind of had
to and while i was doing that i was like
it's fine i would charge it up and try
and like aim it at a certain spot and i
might freeze some stuff but it just
like didn't seem to do anything amazing
to go with it
so i was you can use it to keep a
champion level enemy from
procking their mechanics he's like and
there's and that may be more one of the
the keys about stasis is your super may
not
like stop a boss but the interrupt
mechanic that you get from stasis
may be what it's just beneficial for is
maybe just honestly causing
interrupts and that's more of like
playing in a team
but would i ever use that and think that
thing like a solo nightfall hell no i
don't know i would never pick that over
um
the better option from was it garden
salvation divinity
i would never put that over divinity as
a support weapon
you know what i'm saying right it
doesn't and again like the range on the
grenade launchers definitely always like
hard to art correctly solo player no
maybe support in a raid for like there's
a certain mechanic
you need to build like some stasis stuff
for and grenade you got more options to
shoot it
yeah maybe but let me actually still
have meaning to pick your brain on this
um
you are the lord of the strikes how are
you feeling about the new strike
number one and then obviously strikes in
general
uh the glass way i think it's called yes
yes
okay um i'm trying to remember as much
as i can just details about it
remember it's the stranger talking to
you you go down it's the vex portal at
the bottom the vex keep coming out
and then those um what you call it those
are
the vex the the big one with the shield
the router that rotates
there's a bigger one yeah yeah and then
there's a small one at the end yeah
so you're kind of working your way
through like the vex platforms and stuff
there's some following throughout that
one you get to the bottom
and the big vex portal all i can say is
i'm glad i got conqueror done
yes because i don't think that one's
going to be fun to do with eating
smashy boys uh double hydra action
tight corridors and a whole bunch of
hydras in a small space seems like very
troublesome explosive rounds going
everywhere
very aggressive hyges
yeah so it's like i don't i was like the
world it's in
like all of the underground caves the
vex structures the one
it's not the technocrat but it's that
one might be phallics that you're
fighting in the
very deep subterranean like vex area
yeah one of the three lieutenants that
you fight there
that whole area when you look up in
there that place is gorgeous
like that whole thing so like anything
in that area always looks amazing
because the
vex architecture always looks really
really cool
right yeah i know i know i mean i'm not
like yeah i'm there
after dealing with like the lieutenant
fights as how those
felt now the strikes just don't feel
like they hold
up to those kind of honest
i would even argue that the lieutenant
fight should be strikes all day old and
be
part of it i can't remember i've
listened to a lot of youtube and stuff
about this some people like hey remember
when people said those missions
shouldn't be strikes now we're like can
you make those mission strikes yes
like you make a lieutenant fight a
strike and people would be like all
right
people would be happy to have those in
the strike play list and now we just
have
one and then we have narotta the
non omnigul non
strike playlist yeah it's just shaw hank
i think i've done it for the first
because it's still part of the shorahan
quest and uh
yeah i still got to finish that off
mm-hmm
but yeah i was like that one's mostly
still omnigul not really a lot of
variation to that one
it's just slightly different looking
boss room just more craziness honestly
yeah it's like there's and that's the
point where like the omnical room
now with as much coming out dude
it's oh no no i'm not
i don't know
yeah i put it up there earlier i'll get
i'll get what time it is
i'll get there we're mid discussion sir
i'm saving that stuff video
okay new red light look bro i got these
points i got these points dakota's going
to kill me if she ever drops hers that's
fine
uh no but it's like the i'm just
picturing
boss rooms now for grand master level
stuff when
when the way that we had to go through
some of these things was a little
kind of just insane yeah to get them
done in the first place glitch out
corrupted
yeah um a one that felt more natural was
withering
whispering what the hell was that
festering core that one was more like a
natural
fight like working through the room
working boss damage dealing with spawns
but you had room
in that festering core boss room to like
it's a circle but you had like a certain
amount of cover
yes like omnigul room the new one i mean
the old one was small and crappy anyway
the new one you've got two levels
but there's like ogres that spawn in
there you've got a couple that you've
got
so many guys that spawn out you're going
to be hiding in a corner
maybe like that is going to be such a
quest yeah wyvern champions oh lord that
would be crazy
that would be crazy don't push that put
that evil in the air like that don't do
that
yeah and it's just getting new ideas and
that's one of those that's like the
strike playlist i
understand for lore reasons and darkness
eating the planets why are you gonna
have the strikes go
but when you have a playlist like that
and then you like shrink it by seven and
you add two and then we're gonna get one
more in a future season and one more in
a few
we're gonna get the fallen saber which
isn't gonna be another awful awful
grandmaster i'm sure and then you're
gonna have
uh what the hell is the other one uh
sepiks
sapix yeah yeah i gotta get that which i
gotta get i almost mentioned that to
skype we forgot to mention that to scott
that that song is so iconic because yeah
that one's pretty crazy
um so those are gonna be cool but
we get two more so we're gonna get back
to we have seven then we get
so with eight the new one we'll have ten
which isn't bad but it's like
you lost so many and those were at least
just variety to activities and that's
just a shame
yo blackwing says unstoppable one i'm
pretty sure they're actually overload
because i think they're in there right
now oh
that's gonna be crazy that'll be sick
yeah i don't know if i'm ready to deal
with that at
all yeah an overload guy who smacks you
away and then he gets his health back
no no that is probably my biggest issue
with champions is them getting their
health back
yeah i mean
like we got shotguns on what was it
shotguns on unstoppable
those thoughts what's our first special
anti-champion thing now granted that one
at least makes some sense for those but
for a shotgun you're like what are you
gonna do i gotta wait for him to almost
kill me and then shoot him with the
shotgun
with a shotgun like that's not
terrifying right yeah
they're doing that whole risk reward
stuff they always do i don't know
anyway oh exodus crash by the way
it's like completely deactivated at this
point can they just like
get rid of that like they took it away
again
oh yeah isn't it somebody confirm and
chat for me just so i know i'm not crazy
it's like it was it was switched off of
the nightfall
and then they took it out of the
vanguard rotation
wow and uh lit uh it was funny it
happened the same day
it bugged out on me two different ways
before they took it out
really it bugged out in the first part
with the light pillars
they added it back today no
just just no i'm sorry i am sorry
whoever made that strike i apologize to
all bungie
employees for the creation of exodus
crash i appreciate your work
this is just not not the favorite here
it is
so it is the weakest link goodbye i
really run it
i really run it so like what is it
what's the big
to do what what is it the last fight the
electricity on the floor like what's the
problem i mean there's the electricity
on the floor the fact that he was like
time-gated and used to go away a lot
they changed that a little bit but you
still have to deal with that one
right you've got the light pillars that
you got to run through so your sparrow
gets shot by a random vandal and it
explodes
right right you have the platform that
you've got to stand on where maybe the
electricity guys come up but you have
all the waves of enemies that come while
you defend the point
and it's just like come on it's one of
those slips on
but yeah it's there's there's just
things about that strike
and the fact that the boss fight used to
piss us off more they got rid of like
the immunity phases because it used to
be like seven or eight
yeah it was a lot that's part it's less
now but it's still like
and then he disappears and you're like
ah gotta wait for him then ads come in
you gotta shoot those
the people who've done the grand master
most everybody i know cheesed that one
they like stood on a box basically yeah
yep shot of scream he did that
but is it like a risk running like god
tear in there
i mean theoretically there's like fallen
and stuff so it would be but still it's
yeah it's like four now so it's about
half but it's just i don't know
i've just never never been a fan really
never the only thing i
didn't like about it was that at one
point i think i don't know if this is
still the case
when you get those bounties you'll be
like you'll kill a fallen boss
and there was a time where it was just
that's the was the strength
right that's why it's frustrating yeah
it's like that part i'm like all right
come on because the other one they don't
because you have to
scoring yeah they don't count the barons
um
and the glass way is vex obviously so
you have to go kill a fallen boss in a
strike and you're like
it's the only one so you have to kill
like you know a couple of
like one or maybe two fallen bosses
you're like i have to go run the strike
that i freaking eat yeah
no i agree so yeah fallen saber and then
you're gonna get fallen saber which is
fallen
and then you're gonna turn around and
get um that was the other one i keep
forgetting
what's epics yeah sepiks that's gonna be
one as well
so you got a big shank and a big so then
you'll have three different followers
three different following ones it would
be
i was like that'll be a little better at
least
yeah risk runner is a big love of a lot
of people right now it it fits because
you're facing a lot of fallen in a lot
of places
yep i re i really need to use that
weapon i don't know why
i know we've covered a lot but i feel
like i'm missing missing something
substantial
we talked about we i know we got the
raid we got the contest mode all that
good stuff right
he was like thought have you been
spoiler free on the raid
nope that's a nope sir
[Laughter]
you couldn't avoid it i got caught
man it was kind of it was standing in
the cookie chair
yeah some big news and it was a big news
outlet it was like windows central i was
like
it was like destiny raids been exploded
i'm like damn
so i'm like oh man i shouldn't look cuz
i just
i was i would have made the choice i
want to know
about this clovis thing like i think
it's so
cool so unless i don't all i all i saw
is this i just saw
rooms a couple of rooms a couple of i
don't know what the encounters are
i just know where one of it's gonna be
and uh he said you know he said hey guys
justin's in the fire right now
listen they got me i fell victim but you
still i didn't watch the one that
somebody i guess
tells you about it tells you it kind of
infers what it is i did
i don't know all i know is i the locale
of like
the place is i haven't pretty so i've
tried that pretty amazing and out there
and i was just like
okay so that part i i couldn't contain
my curiosity with that
but um as far as everything else with
the specifics i didn't watch anymore
it's just a matter of environment but um
the reason why i felt victim is because
i like going into those those out of the
deep sectors
the ones that are the research
facilities where it's clovis brace tech
and the um i know you know about
shall we talk about it i mean this is
super spoiler about
the little figurine that represents
someone
that a mpc that we talk to often
do we that's that's all they're gonna
say we're gonna go full spoilers here in
a second so
um we're already a long point in the
episode you guys have been here for a
while if you do want to find us in
places you guys know where to find a
socially soil alert coming up in five
four three two one
get out of here we go if y'all wanna
know so uh again this is not raid y'all
i'm just talking about when um
the lore from my understanding when you
get the
what is it the version that you have the
legendary collectors whatever whatever
okay
so from my understand yeah there we go
so
yo the banshee day yo
yo so what's up with banshee apparently
one of the conscious this clovis bray
all that one
one of his consciousness all this time
really
yes yes so that's one of them so
apparently
there was a and then if you look in the
brave facility and you go inside
you always it's that big open room they
got um almost like laboratories
and then there's a go you go up a step
to the right and there's office space
in the office space you'll see
a little miniature figure yeah i saw
that i think i just didn't catch it see
with the thing that the like something
got the head i was like
yo so um yeah
like again and i guess with the wipes so
she's black legs thank you i'm inviting
my leftovers
yeah like the law yo
shout out to the lord team and they've
been
on fire this whole joint between that he
chose to wipe his memory
permanently and make a new life yes yet
yo
crazy implications this raid that's why
i felt victim because i'm like the law
is so good
what are we going to be doing i just got
to know where we're talking
like the big question is do you think
post raid on
saturday or sunday if it's beaten in 24
hours or not
shout out to hopefully.2402.
do you think we unlock do you think it
unlocks something
do you think i not a planet because
they've been pretty clear to keep
expectations in check we've got
cosmodrome we've got a big ass europa
yeah
but do you think it unlocks missions
before i answer that anything like that
question
wasn't was i am i confused where i
thought the hunts were supposed to take
place on the dreaming city
they're there too i've done something
there yeah oh yeah so someone i'm
telling you
like the first two are fallen those are
a tangled shore the other two prey
options
those are always dreaming sitting oh
i've been i've done that just once you
unlock it yeah
got it got it got it got it got it um
it's tough because part of me feels it
wraps
up nicely with europa
and i struggle to see how they link it
to some
other place but i don't know
i don't know man this i i'm dying to
know
the implications of what the hell he is
doing
and all this vex tech and darkness and
this guy he's just
clove is just dirt bag he don't care
about human life
log is his existence is he's out there i
just want to see what these are i like
chad
diana's like imagine it hints to the
vault of glass and it's like the vex
want revenge for all of what clovis did
to him
could be a segway could be a say because
we got to think about this right
narratively how they gonna bring the
vault of glass in i'm still wondering
that
i don't know how you get we we entered
it from a patrol space with the gateway
on venus
which means somewhere some way there's
gonna have to be some
gateway entrance theoretically they
would might want to have a similar
encounter unless you're just going to
warp inside
yeah but either way like we opened a
specific gateway to the vault of glass
because
thematically by the story atheon was
kind of a pretty big deal
yes so if we go through all of that to
get into their
vault per se like you know cracking a
bank vault
right you have to go through some way to
get into there again right but the big
question is
why and how now right what they're
saying in chat is theoretically like
the vex are pissed because he was
basically plucking them out of a portal
stealing their radial area using that to
make exos
and you know pairing that with the
pyramid powers and the darkness and the
radial area and the memory wipes and all
that crazy stuff
too much stuff in the pot yeah i was
like yeah just so which is brew from
hell right there
they got the brew right now cook it up
vex equals time travel gobble gobble the
goo
[Music]
facts uh yeah i don't know i mean
here's to me there's two threads where
this thing gonna go
it's either you're gonna go and finish
this vex thing
right with either their revenge or what
he opened and he doesn't realize what he
did
or we still got zevo rap
situation well zevu has to be
like the seasonal content i feel is
going to be building towards witch queen
every season now you're probably going
to have like any tv show
you've got your intro to introduce zebra
wrath and the t's towards witch queen
you're gonna have your filler episodes
in the middle right
one or two of these seasons in the
middle aren't gonna have anything but an
offshoot story yeah offshoot most likely
yeah um then you're gonna start ty the
last one is going to be
the direct lead into witch queen
something like that
and then so that's how we're going to
get to her
but it's like then you still have the
whole key of the vex but that was the
thing about zebra or wrath is that she
actually
uh can never say all right kiera
yeah yeah it's like there's that vex
yeah
yeah vex mine that's like but it's like
kind of darkness or high it's related to
kind of
it's been messed with by them but i'm
wondering if that ever comes into play
as well
yeah we got a lot going on i don't know
this is one i'm truly curious when we
beat this raid
what the implications are yeah i'm
saying and we know it has to be a bit
more than clovis it's just i feel it's
more of what clovis was experimenting
with
and then obviously when you find out
where it is
but um yeah like i can't wait man
and then we still got the crow running
around like this
is the current you got marisov at some
point yeah
yeah marissa running around look at new
red with the phonetic spelling
i got two of them in there cute q
warrior y'all rory
okay are you i still butchered it
sorry about the stream taking a crap by
the way i can't help that one at this
point that's all good
but that's what i got man i can't wait
for this saturday
placing the boots up man yeah
who oh love this
where is it dropping just random uh it's
related to the hunts i haven't actually
dug into where it's at i need to do that
but it's related to the hunt
i don't know if it's when you unlock it
rank 10 or if there's certain thing or
if you need to use it on the hunts and
charge it up or what but it's something
related to hunts i gotta dig in
figure out what it is i gotta work on
that um
i gotta get my necrotic grip today i'm
i'm getting close to light levels so
that
that uh sector shouldn't scare me no
more
all right i did want to ask you on
what's up cosmetically to kind of wrap
it up as i'm looking through the season
pass
the season pass armor related to all
these rathborn hunts yay
nay thoughts kind of trash
seriously oh i thought you might
actually like mine looks i thought yours
looked pretty clean i thought mine was a
bit too much but i thought you're going
to see that
where are you seeing that i don't know i
mean maybe i'm looking at the wrong
thing maybe i'm disgusting you talking
about the season
pass here go look at that and then
season the hunt and it's literally like
scroll down to
nope uh where is it exotics and gear you
should just see the season pass and it's
just a picture of the three of them
it looks pretty good exotics and gear
uh just scroll down calendar
news we're at um
so you see like barrier fangs like the
exotic quest zebra wrath duality
and then below that oh you mean the
actual reward path
yeah all right so the ornaments for the
season pass
okay yeah i mean right now they're
showing the hunter stuff
keep going i'm looking i'm scrolling to
the right
do you see like the right no no no
there's a picture
like there's a picture of the whole
thing yeah
okay once you're on the season pass page
yes scroll down the page you'll see rise
of a high of god
i see included with caesar hunt i see
the hawk moon
silver bundle calendar news media and
then
uh faq girl up from silver bundle
you'll see hawkmoon you'll see season
pass season pass where you'll see
like just above the actual season pass
like rankings all
for the free seasonal armor that one
yeah oh i mean
that's the ornaments that come with the
season pass
[Music]
yes that is i was just i remember you
know me i'm warlocked by it so i'm just
like
hey do i laugh for me fame like the
helmet is okay
i don't know how i feel about this
little sash thing i feel like
like titan looking strong look look at
the military clip you know what i'm
saying like
tight looking strong it's something
about the wall like that i can't even
tell
the hunter you know there's usually no
disturbing usually that's the
discernible hood
wait hold on hunter's left yeah oh hunch
is the best one
hulk is the best one time is okay
i just don't me i'm not warlock's front
and center i'm just not feeling it
i can't get jiggy with that i can't get
you okay so you got that
now the one that actually even my
brother and i think somebody else bought
was the um
the black armory yes seasonal set
from eververse that's the one i cop you
know who's rocking it out
that might get you yo you know yo i got
a shout out about it's the first
warlock listen i pride myself in having
being the most fly warlock out here
there's no one i've rarely seen
anyone dress their wall like this flies
i'm just gonna put it out there gotta
stroke myself with a bat
you know whose warlock game is serious
wi-fi shout out to your wifi had an
outfit with that joint on i said bro
what [ __ ] is that yo
i was like yo i hate the just to steal
your swag with that
shader that you got
man yeah yeah that set that you know
what's funny i
bought that and because you know how i'm
i'm captain
waste a module just to you know upgrade
so right
that set has kept me from wasting stuff
because all i do now is throw
any blue or any legendary and turn it
into that
with that ornament oh man i love it love
it man
yeah yeah yeah but salute salute to that
set yeah cause i say i really care for
the other one but that set
really good very very black armory vibe
very easy throw up on it yes yes yes
that oh yeah the bond is good hey shout
out i got it my man my fight we gotta
bring my fight back
he's rocking with the black armory bond
with it the big huge oh
it was clean it's clean so i gotta i
gotta wait till you see my sheet uh
i i'm coming back on them i'm coming
back i got some style for them now
but yeah that's my joy nice yes
yeah i mean i think that's it i'm gonna
let you wrap it up while i knock out
this for new red who's been uh
feeling yes it's what's up baby you know
what we're here for
we're here for that fitness y'all y'all
know what it is new rad you've been very
patient sir
you know what i'm saying we've been
trying to get this man to get these
setups in
you know what i'm saying we're still a
pandemic still out here man gyms are
open
but look you can do things in your house
look my man e is out here
we're about to give you some textbook
form going on right now
get your sit-ups in y'all you're staying
in the house look at that look at that
perform there elbow to the knee
you know where's the paws at the top
where's the paws at the top
come on now there you go i mean that's
what i'm talking about like this is the
type of
fitness education and entertainment we
give you we're promoting health and good
vibes
you're not gonna get this anywhere only
at the last we're only at the campfire
y'all look at oh oh well yo he's showing
off he's starting right there look at
this slow rock
see that's core right there yeah you
gotta have that guy good quarter i call
v belly but you gotta have a good call
to do that and this is what i'm talking
about right now
shout out to the destiny show everybody
in the chat yo he's out here my man is
out here
he's showing you how to do these things
bro he's always doing the push-up yo we
getting the call we get a two-for-one
right now you're getting two for one
special
getting that we should get him to do
diamonds though we should get him to do
diamonds but i don't want to be evil
[Music]
yes sir yes sir shout out the new rad
sitting on those points
i gave you guys a couple but my elbows
not 100 yet
all right elbows down i was saying maybe
next time we get the diamond push
really i can do a few of them fresh
level
right now my elbow's still not 100 so
now we got to protect the elbow protect
the elbow y'all
know dolly she said we got to have yeah
how long is she got the longest yeah we
definitely yeah we we
this is a power we're making up for a
lost show we did last week both be
we're busy so we figured with the sky
interview we still had to talk to you
after it so
thank y'all for rocking out man this is
this is what's up man
got the dab going justin said this is
the content i pay you to see
it's like with the guns out man this is
what we do
before covent
[Laughter]
we lit right here
he says all that titan melee he been
doing
gotta work out him got it gotta keep up
gotta keep up bro
i literally do punch for part of my job
so bought his job
for real for real there's not a lot of
kicking in this game though i will say
that yeah not a lot of kicking a lot of
kicking was good
johnny utah what up you already know
so yeah man it's a good one good show
today good wrap
yeah a little extra long but we got our
we got our hour with skye
yes sir when you guys see that one out
there um
if you guys are watching try not to
actually tag bungie on that one
just you know yes we don't want to get
him in trouble yeah yeah
we did he did us a silence so yeah just
a fleece salute just shout out that you
enjoyed the episode as much as you guys
can on the twitters because you know
people do follow and see it but yes
trying not to
call it out too much exactly
i probably tweeted that out somebody
from the community team's like go watch
this episode somebody's like all right
did you do anything
no first time somebody silently watched
in the background
bags bags um
well yeah man ready for the raid ready
to get rocking man
yeah saturday is gonna be interesting
any uh
i think this will probably huh oh okay
no i was just gonna say like um i think
the way the leveling has been because
even i haven't been quite as hardcore
between everything going on i think this
potentially will be
very competitive yeah very competitive
most people in it
like 1230s not bit like if you would
have tried because i haven't even been
trying that hard
i'll hit 12 30 on one of mine and i
haven't even split three characters
wow mine's mostly been just one yeah
sound like me
i'm just what i'm thinking about right
now is what i'm running in there with
you know i mean as far as
i mean i can go all tried and true you
know uh well
phoenix protocol thinking about going in
there probably with
cold denial that new fusion
and maybe us depend on the encounter
xeno
i slept on anarchy anarchy is
stupid powerful oh it is yeah
he's still one of my go-to yes zero's a
go-to for long range but if it's one of
those bosses that sits in a spot
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you know i will
definitely say like as i'm sitting here
looking at the raid emblem though for
that boss
yes it looks like it has almost a um
where'd it go what i pictures not as i
care too much about the world of zodiac
but is the
it's very symmetrical almost like i
would picture like gemiini and twins
i would love it if they would ever do
two bosses you're fighting at the same
time
probably five i mean that would be like
why have again i'm speculating here
because i haven't looked but like you
know there's a big guess of like what
the boss is going to be is like
what if there's two can you imagine
fighting
two what's the axis
from siva imagine fighting two of him in
an arena
that would be crazy yes dakota we are
streaming it
nice so it looks like the team it's uh
myself
um attic gaming forte wilhelm scream
cat daddy and i'm miss sinister sinister
so that's looking like this
what a good crew got a decent crew got a
decent crew you know
hopefully we get past one encounter yes
yeah i was like when i did um i did last
wish
blind uh i did it with mano
uh who will be on here in a few weeks
actually uh yes
and that one we got to the consecrative
mind so we got to the third encounter
kind of got everything figured out just
could not get like the damage balance at
that point that was it because you had
to be pretty perfect for the
the gambit run on that one yo did you
hear
um what durat said he said um someone
did the math and with the extra ammo for
the cattle for leviathan breath
the dps now matches xenophage wow i
gotta get the hands like i gotta get the
catalyst and see what's up
that's void too with precision
interesting and it has a little um anti
i think it's an unstoppable yeah that's
unstoppable
yeah yeah definitely man it is what it
is we got some fun
yeah it'll be a blast so yeah next week
um for you guys heads up if you are
watching or listening as we go we are
gonna have travis
back travis north up last time he is
working on the review
mcclunkey uh he's working on the review
for
ign and he's definitely gonna get a raid
group together i almost ended up running
with him but i think he jumped on a
group of consoles like dude you do not
want me on a console team i mean
i would be terrible because my
controller skills are
trash and we not doing them frames until
december 8th
yeah i wouldn't do that anyway but yeah
i know
so your frames get your frames again yep
tie guy travis will be coming back so
that'll be an awesome one
had a blast last time so that'll be next
week friday night
that should be an awesome episode
because we'll cover post raid his review
kind of get a full wrap on everything at
that point and see
i'm not sitting here just like staring
at the calendar is kind of the last
thing to wonder what remains and we've
got
uncover the secrets of europa through
january 12th
that's some time trials
will start when the day he comes back
so we will see how those adept weapons
are
and then after that the only thing that
remains is iron banner the donning and
more which seems to be like
the quest for hawkmoon the quest for
cloud strike like all those actually
seem to be quests which is cool
so there's a little more to those we'll
have to see how that all turns out but
overall lots to discuss then but for now
i think that's mostly all we got so
if you got anything coming up for your
world and then we'll wrap this thing up
because it's been a long night but
you guys are amazing yeah shout out to
everybody rocking yeah man i love
podcasts every sunday the lord's day
let's keep it low we got somebody from
the statue community from uh
dolph castle x dc open mike this guy's
really
just trying to merge the communities
which is um like comics
you know statues video games all this
stuff
it all intertwines man he's a big person
in the community
so check him out we'll be doing that
we'll touch on his video game history as
well as talk about all the latest stuff
that's going on we may even do a special
we may do an uh an award a game award
special with the kind of tradition that
we do in our podcast whenever the game
award nominees are announced
we will amongst all the lords pick who
we think will win that category
then once the awards happen the show
after will tally up
and then you'll crown your lord who's
the who's the person that's winning you
already know i got like six ghosts
what's your game of year it's ghost it's
ghosts i honestly think it's mine too
yeah it's my uh because i was obviously
debating between i didn't play doom
right uh final fantasy 7 remake i'm
waiting i've heard good things but yes
my like i honestly thought it was going
to be harder for me between
last of us two and ghosts yeah because
last of us two was a hell of a journey
and i got done i was like that's a game
i'm not gonna forget
ghosts you did both for you to say that
that's big because you've done well i've
not finished
i've not finished last of us you didn't
finish last of us
like last of us is a uh it's a journey
and it's one that i won't forget
but ghosts for a game especially like
i and then the fact that legends came
later
yeah that that is the game video game
package for everything you'd ever want
like no that i mean yeah i think that's
mine i think that has to be mine
mm-hmm no yeah you guys think miles
morales i don't i
it was nominated for something but it
wasn't in game of the year category oh
man i can't wait to play that though
i've heard so many good things
yeah so we got that so yeah come check
us out sunday
11 a.m eastern law podcast you already
know and
also you catch it on twitch if you are
not on youtube and then i obviously uh
lords of gaming.net
salute you know all the support we
really appreciate a lot of cool articles
a lot of cool guys if you guys are
playing demon souls you guys are playing
miles around
go to largergaming.net we got some cool
walkthroughs some cool stuff in there
check that out and um yeah shout out to
y'all my family he said last of us had
story but ghosts had style baby you
already know
jen sakaya the building ninjas and
cherry blossoms on deck
you already know but um yeah man check
this out and then obviously
yo last word salute man love what we're
doing
love to see the support you know seeing
guys like sky comfortable to come on
have a good time
you know we wouldn't be here without you
guys man so salute to you guys for sure
to support
and uh appreciate it man but eat what
you got
uh for me i'm probably gonna i'm still
trying to make sure my streams get
better so i will be working on that my
internet connection should be better now
so
if i can resolve what is going on like
my speeds should be solid
and i just gotta fix cause they like
came out and tested everything all's
good speeds faster
but i just gotta see what's up um so
i'll be working on that one
i still want to play godfall has gotten
like you know got like a six on ign and
you see it in different places
there's some fun to be said about the
combat but then when you get to the
in-game
i'm people are saying it's like not so
much and that's why honestly something
like outrider still has me even more
intrigued which is good
um but for me like demon souls is my
next one when i get a
when i get a breather time between
destiny and i like kind of get to a
decent point in godfall
you guys know i'm going to be playing
demon souls so stay tuned on twitch
also watch my uh twitter as well because
it will be
once i figure out all this streaming
stuff i will be experimenting streaming
on youtube as well just to test the
waters and see
um maybe one works better than the other
we'll just honestly have to find out
but for me it's honestly just like
having fun and hacking slash combat
between shooting
because shooting's fun but like godfall
and demon souls while godfall may not be
as
like good for some people and stuff yeah
if i just have fun in combat it's hard
for me to go wrong
bro with that brother ain't nothing
wrong with that man um
but yeah we were trying to figure out
where we were gonna go raid for tonight
once we wrap this thing up
um you guys feeling like the man of the
vibes
let's get the vibes vibe man we gotta
get the
news in here so we're gonna go over
shout out to that man if you go follow
him on twitter and just wake up to that
man's tweets
seriously guys that is he is fantastic
so
great dude this has been amazing thank
you guys for an ultra long episode
cognito for staying awake for this one
but your sleep schedule's going to go
back to hell yeah
so this actually worked fine for me so
yeah
well thank you guys very much um for
episode 128
can't believe we keep getting that high
november 19th thank you guys very much
the guest was amazing you guys are
awesome
have an awesome one we'll see you guys
if we're waiting for this episode it has
been
the last word